bonjour à tous remercie tout d'abord
d'être venus aussi nombreux ce soir pour
la conférence de jean marc jancovici
désolé si certaines personnes n'ont pas
de places assises mais malheureusement
les locaux sont des places un peu limité
il en reste au premier rang
donc la conférence qui va suivre a été
organisée par l'association du noise
d'agroparistech c'est une association
qui existe dans neuf antennes de grandes
écoles à paris et à lyon et qui veut
dire nouvel observatoire de l'innovation
sociale et environnementale
donc c'est une association étudiante qui
vise à informer organiser des rencontres
participer à la recherche de solutions
et de réflexion autour d'initiatives
principalement de l'économie sociale et
solidaire et de l'écologie donc ce soir
nous accueillons avec plaisir jean marc
jancovici qui est très actif dans les
domaines du changement climatique et de
l'énergie depuis la fin des années 90
avant de vous laisser donc avec le mâle
jancovic si on voulait vous dire qu'à la
fin de la conférence
on vous invite tous à venir prendre un
petit pot et un petit verre à la cafet
qui est à la sortie vers la droite du
centre d'agroparistech pour discuter de
ce que vous avez entendu échanger avec
les autres et réfléchir ensemble donc
belle conférence à tous et je laisse la
parole à me jean marc jancovici
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir alors j'ai le plaisir de faire
ma première conférence low tech depuis
longtemps parce que mon ordinateur est
en arrêt maladie
depuis ce matin il a décidé qu'il se
mettait en grève lui aussi je sais pas
peut-être que les solidaires avec les
gens de la ratp ou de la sncf
voilà donc pas de présentation donc je
vais tout faire avec les mains du coup
j'ai une bonne et une mauvaise nouvelle
la mauvaise c'est que ce sera plus court
et que je vais essayer de pallier par
les mots ce que j'aurais dû vous montrer
des images la bonne nouvelle c'est que
du coup il y aura plein de temps pour
les questions parce que je vais
probablement pas vous bassiner une heure
avec juste un discours alors - non mais
la personne qui à l'interrupteur
probablement oui le le sujet le sujet
dont je voulais vous parler enfin dont
je vais vous parler soit dit en passant
ce soir c'est l'imbrication du domaine
qui est le vôtre c'est à dire
l'agriculture et de deux domaines que je
connais un peu qui sont l'énergie et les
changements climatiques
alors avant de rentrer dans
l'intervention gelé quelques casquettes
qui sont les miennes la plus importante
à vos yeux probablement sec super d'une
agréable mais elle vient de sortir
donc elle n'est pas là pour raconter des
bêtises ce soir les quelques casquettes
sinon un peu significatif qui sont les
miennes c'est que j'ai fondée en 2007
une société de conseil qui s'appelle
carbone 4 qui fait aujourd'hui une
cinquantaine de personnes ou votre école
est très dignement représentée puisque
vous en avez trois ou quatre qui
travaillent chez nous et qui tente de
voir ce qu'on peut faire d'intelligent à
la frontière de la contrainte énergie
climat dont je viens de vous parler et
du métier des gens qu'on a en face de
nous li autrement qu'est ce qu'ils
peuvent trouver comme voies et moyens de
composer avec la contrainte en question
j'ai également fondé en 2010 une
association qui s'appelle de chiffres
project qui est une association qui
milite pour la décarbonation de
l'économie je peux vous expliquer
pourquoi
et enfin j'ai une troisième casquette
qui est que j'enseigne dans la seule
école qui pour le moment n'a pas encore
été déménagée sur le plateau de saclay
c'est à dire les mines juste à côté
j'ai vécu en direct le drame de la faim
de grillons donc c'est pas la peine de
m'en parler
je connais par coeur le
voilà et très m'arrive de faire des
interventions à droite et à gauche qui
pour recycler un peu ce que je sais ce
que je sais c'est pas à vous que je vais
apprendre que l'agriculture est une
activité très très ancien chez les
hommes puisque c'est ce qui a accompagné
la sédentarisation de notre espèce ça
fait une dix mille ans à peu près qu'on
s'est sédentarisé ce que vous ne savez
peut-être pas c'est que la
sédentarisation de notre espèce a été le
contrecoup de la stabilisation du
système climatique terrestre
il ya dix mille ans donc il ya dix mille
ans le au cours du quaternaire sert les
derniers millions d'années
le système climatique planétaire a
beaucoup varié le système climatique
varie de toute façon en permanence parce
que le système climatique c'est une
grosse machine thermodynamique et les
éléments qui permettent à la machine de
fonctionner sont eux mêmes des éléments
qui peuvent varier
par exemple la puissance du soleil peut
varier au cours du temps la dérive des
continents en fait que vous avez de la
neige vous en avez pas de la glace où
vous en avez pas là où le soleil arrive
donc c'est plus ou moins réfléchi voilà
donc vous avez un certain nombre
d'éléments comme ça qu'ils influent et
qui font que le climat paris il ya dix
mille ans le
la fnath la terre sort de la dernière
grande variation climatique que notre
espèce est connue qui s'appelle une des
glaciations donc une des glaciations
c'est vous passer de l'ère glaciaire où
la france ressemblait au nord de la
sibérie en gros et puis vous n'aviez pas
d'erasmus parce que les scandinaves
étaient sous la glace de même que les
canadiens à au monde qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui qui est un monde dans lequel
si on fait pas les andouilles
il ya des écosystèmes qui sont
essentiellement forestiers aux moyennes
latitudes et à l'équateur est donc cette
ce climat j'ai envie de dire
interglaciaire c'est comme ça qu'on
l'appelle dans le jargon des géologues
démaria dix mille ans et ça permet à
notre appel à notre espèce de
sédentariser et de se mettre à pratiquer
l'agriculture avec l'agriculture sont
arrivés tout un tas d'autres pratiques
non par exemple la comptabilité
parce qu'il fallait compter les
troupeaux et les récoltes et l'écriture
enfin tout un tas de trucs sont arrivés
avec avec ça donc l'agriculture cet
ancien l'énergie c'est encore plus
anciens l'énergie c'est encore plus
anciens pour deux raisons la première
c'est parce que c'est une grandeur
physique qui dont la définition ne
dépend pas de nous encore l'énergie on
croit que c'est un sujet de débat
citoyen de très bien c'est probablement
vrai mais avant ça c'est une grandeur
physique dans la définition ne dépend
pas de nous alors pour ceux d'entre vous
qui ne sont pas trop hostile à la
physique notre post il part dont le
physique normalement tout le monde dans
cette salle vous vous rappelez
probablement que l'énergie c'est par
définition ce qui quantifie le
changement d'état d'un système c'est ça
l'énergie en physique c'est la
quantification du changement d'état d'un
système donc des vous avez un système
qui change de température de formes de
couleurs de vitesse etc
vous avez de l'énergie qui intervient et
inversement dès que quelque chose change
dans le monde qui nous entoure de
l'énergie intervient alors l'énergie
intervient mais elle intervient jamais
sol pour se manifester elle a besoin de
ce qu'on appelle un convertisseur donc
utiliser de l'énergie en fait c'est
mobiliser un convertisseur qu'on va
alimenter avec cette énergie et qui va
nous rendre des services sous forme
d'une autre énergie pour la
photosynthèse par exemple c'est un
convertisseur je prends des photos et je
vous fais du glucose la conversion
l'homme est un convertisseur d'énergie
je mange grâce à la science des agro qui
ont permis de faire de délicieux
hamburger donc je mange et grâce à ça je
peux fournir de la chaleur beaucoup sur
les animaux à sang chaud du mouvement à
peu
et puis donc le l'énergie est quelque
chose qui est présent dans l'univers
depuis qu'hier un univers l'histoire de
l'homme et de l'énergie en fait est une
histoire très ancienne puisque depuis
que nous existons nous avons un rapport
avec l'énergie on s'alimente et donc ont
fourni de la chaleur et du mouvement et
la transition énergétique est également
quelque chose de très ancien chez les
hommes puisque comme on est des animaux
aucune grosse cervelle on a compris
qu'on pouvait essayer de s'approprier
l'énergie d'autres choses
pas juste la nôtre et notre propre corps
ça fait très longtemps qu'on a compris
ça alors on a démarré avec le feu il ya
un demi million d'années on s'est
approprié l'énergie de la combustion
probablement essentiellement pour faire
fuir les prédateurs
et puis avec le temps c'est approprié
plein d'autres énergies alors on s'est
approprié l'énergie d'autres
convertisseur biologique c'est les
animaux de trait et l'esclavagisme
on s'est approprié des énergies
renouvelables il ya quelques siècles
toutes les énergies que nous utilisions
étaient renouvelables on utilisait la
force du vent pour faire tourner les
moulins et avancer les bateaux on
utilisait la force de l'eau pour faire
tourner des moulins il y avait des
moulins à eau partout dans l'antiquité
en europe
donc on s'est approprié la chaleur du
soleil on faisait sécher la luzerne avec
du soleil maintenant il ya des séchoirs
agace beaucoup plus beaucoup mieux mais
il fut une époque où les récoltes
séchait essentiellement au soleil et
donc on s'est approprié toutes les
énergies renouvelables et puis soit dit
en passant un monde 100 % renouvelable
j'ai au moins un point d'échantillonnage
pour savoir que c'est possible c'est une
humanité agricole de 500 millions
d'habitants avec 30 ans d'espérance de
vie à la naissance
voilà ça je suis totalement certain que
ça marche puisque on l'a fait une fois
penser qu'on va faire un monde 100 %
renouvelable avec 8 milliards de bipède
vivant 70 ans d'espérance de vie à la
naissance est acheté un ordinateur à la
fnac pour mille euros c'est mois suivant
beaucoup moins suivre mais j'y
reviendrai probablement au moment des
questions donc ont donc toutes les
énergies renouvelables et puis il ya
deux siècles quelques ingénieurs géniaux
trouve que on peut encore domestique et
d'autres convertisseur qui s'appelle des
machines alors évidemment les moulins et
les moulins sont déjà des machines mais
lassé des machines fait de métal et
qu'ils vont être capables d'utiliser
encore une autre énergie que votre corps
évidemment pas capables d'utiliser qui
sont des choses qui brûlent alors du
bois au début les premières forge
utiliser du bois du reste on a largement
déforester la france grâce à ça c'est le
charbon qui a sauvé les forêts dans
beaucoup de pays occidentaux
et puis
on s'est mis à utiliser du charbon qu'on
appelle soit ditt en passant du charbon
de terre au début par opposition charbon
de bois puis du pétrole puis du gaz à
pluie du l'hydroélectricité plus du
nucléaire alors j'ai pas mes graphiques
favori pour vous le dire vous allez me
croire sur facture mais l'histoire
énergétique des hommes depuis la
révolution industrielle n'est pas une
histoire de substitution entre énergie
dit autrement en valeur absolue le
charbon n'a pas de substituer le bois et
le pétrole n'a pas substituer le charbon
tous assez a ajouté l'un sur l'autre
donc quand vous regardez l'utilisation
d'énergie de l'humanité c'est un
empilement d'énergie les unes sur les
autres et alors pourquoi est ce qu'on a
envie d'utiliser de plus en plus
d'énergie parce que utiliser de plus en
plus d'énergie à cause de la définition
même de l'énergie s'est transformé de
plus en plus le monde qui nous entoure
c'est donc devenir superman utiliser de
l'énergie c'est utilisé à notre profit
un nombre croissant de machines qui vont
à notre place donc vraiment superman
voir très loin
un télescope transporter très vite un
camion un bateau lever très lourd
une grue transformer très très vite un
haut fourneau et c'est donc on est
vraiment devenu superman grâce à
l'énergie et pour vous donner une idée
qui dans cette salle a déjà mixé de la
soupe
bon c'est bien itron foot comme on dit
est ce que vous savez quelle est la
puissance d'un mixeur à soupe qui
connaît la puissance d'un mixeur à soupe
non non c'est le bon ordre de grandeur
500 quelques centaines de watts est ce
que vous savez quelle est la puissance
moyenne d'une paire de jambes en action
100 watts et je peux vous dire 100 watts
vous n'êtes pas mauvais parce que vous
me faites de 1000 mètres de dénivelé
dans la journée
une paire de bras en actions d'iwate
donc quand vous avez un mixeur à soupe
dans la main vous avez trois à cinq
cyclistes en train de pédaler dans la
main qui connaît la puissance d'un
aspirateur ici qui a déjà inspiré quand
même nom cette crade et la plus qui
fonde la soupe un aspirateur ça fait un
kilowatt avec un kilo en train kilowatts
et 1 kg a été mis d'accord donc un
aspirateur y [ __ ] comme dix à quinze
cyclistes qui connaît la puissance d'un
tracteur dans la salle
voilà tout ce qu'ils savent pas devrait
aller dehors tout de suite alors
un tracteur fait effectivement de
l'ordre de 100 chevaux
c'est à dire de l'ordre de 70 kilowatts
alors si vous êtes céréalier dans la
gauche vous serez à 150
si vous avez un petit enjambeur dans une
petite parcelle vous serez plutôt à 30
ou à 20 mais en gros vous êtes à
quelques dizaines de kilomètres ce qui
veut dire quatre acteurs tirent aussi
fort que quelques centaines de paires de
jambes il tire aussi fort que quelques
centaines de paires de jambes ce que là
où je veux en venir c'est que le rapport
entre l'énergie et l'agriculture c'est
que l'énergie a permis de diviser par un
facteur d'un on va dire 20 à 20 à 40 la
part des actifs qui travaillent dans
l'agriculture il ya deux siècles les
deux tiers des français travailler dans
l'agriculture d'accord donc 67% des
français travailler dans l'agriculture
ça veut dire qu'un paysan de il ya deux
siècles il est capable de se nourrir lui
plus d'une demi personne qui fait autre
chose
d'accord c'est ça que ça veut dire donc
il n'est pas très productif
aujourd'hui est ce que vous savez quelle
est la part des français qui travaillent
dans l'agriculture ah ça vous savez donc
vous avez eu des cours d'économie pas
d'aspirateurs mais d'économie
effectivement de 3% ce qui veut dire
qu'on a divisé par 30
la quantité de gens qui travaillent dans
l'agriculture
est ce que vous savez pas combien on a
multiplié la production si j'inclus les
pâturages globalement par deux à trois
si je veux limite aux céréales c'est
plutôt par huit ce qui veut dire qu'un
agriculteur aujourd'hui il est en gros
une centaine de fois plus productif que
ne l'était un agriculteur d'avant-guerre
moyennant quoi vous manger du steak à
tous les repas avec vingt fois moins de
personnes qui travaillent dans les
campagnes qu'est ce qui a permis sa
l'énergie l'énergie et l'énergie
l'énergie a permis ça parce que la force
de traction d'un tracteur remplacent les
animaux de trait qui avait besoin de
surfaces qui maintenant sont libérés
pour l'alimentation humaine parce que
les tracteurs libère des paires de bras
et des paires de jambes qui avant avait
besoin de passer dans les champs pour
semer faucher désherber et c'est parce
que vous avez d'autres auxiliaires
énergétique qui aujourd'hui travaillent
de façon surpuissante dans l'agriculture
qui sont nommément les
usine d'engrais et les mines de
phosphate et de potasse alors les mines
c'est ça fonctionne avec des engins
miniers donc c'est des mines à ciel
ouvert là comme les mines de lignite
dans la sympathique avec des grands
engins d'excavation vous en avez
quelques unes dans le monde qui alimente
le monde dans son ensemble
ensuite avant c'était les animaux et les
hommes qui pis est affichée dans les
champs donc c'était comme ça qu'on
recycle et localement l'azoté le
phosphore et le potassium
aujourd'hui c'est plus du tout comme ça
qu'on fait on est tout un cycle ouvert
et ensuite vous avez un deuxième
auxiliaires surpuissant qui sont les
transports à laval alors vous avez
également les phytosanitaires mais c'est
moins important
les engrais pour ceux d'entre vous qui
savent pas les engrais azotés s'est
fabriqué avec du gaz alors il a beau
être naturel c'est une énergie fossile
la façon dont on faut que ça quand on
fait des ammonitrates on a besoin
d'ammoniaque et pour faire de l'ammoniac
vous commencez par craquer du méthane
c'est à dire du gaz naturel mais pétrole
et naturel le charbon aussi et les
chutes de pierres sont naturels donc on
commence par craquer du gaz et avec ça
vexe gaz craquer on récupère l'hydrogène
et saas associées à la zone de l'air ça
vous permet de faire de l'ammoniac et
c'est le début de la chimie des engrais
est évidemment le carbone par dans l'air
sous forme de co2 dans cette histoire
donc fabriquer de l'hydrogène
quel début de l'activité en grèce a fait
plein de co2 sait très bien faire ça
fait plein de co2 donc les engrais
azotés sont faits avec du gaz énergies
fossiles le tracteur dans les champs
avance avec du diesel énergies fossiles
et vous avez une énorme dépendance à
laval également
de l'agriculture moderne qui est que un
camion sur trois en france transportent
quelque chose qui se mange le niveau
d'autosuffisance alimentaire de l'île de
france de l'ordre de 6%
dit autrement si demain matin je
supprime les camions vous et je meurs de
faim mais littéralement au sens premier
du terme
si on revient aux charrettes à bras et
au carriole à cheval pour alimenter
paris paris peut être alimenté par un
disque agricole dont le rayon et une à
deux journées de transport à pied ou à
cheval
ça ne fait pas comme dirait l'autre ça
le fait pas aujourd'hui l'hinterland qui
permet d'alimenter une mégapole de 10
millions d'habitants
c'est même pas la france c'est le monde
sait même pas la france c'est le monde
vos fruits et légumes viennent d'espagne
du pérou l'avocat y est du pérou les
enfin plein de trucs vi du maroc etc
c'est le monde d'accord et vous avez une
partie à la pêche est faite au milieu de
l'océan indien afin de hausser le monde
d'accord donc sans transport abondant ça
ne flotte pas cette affaire là
soit dit en passant la spécialisation
agricole qu'on a aujourd'hui c'est à
dire je fais des céréales mon client
c'est un triture heures qui va me faire
des animaux des aliments pour animaux
puis ensuite on va aller mettre ça dans
les habitations à quelques centaines de
vaches puis ensuite et c'est ça va
partir chez bongrain ou ou lactalis pour
faire du fromage puis et c'est sa flotte
pas dans un monde sans pétrole ce truc
là ça ne marche pas vous avez besoin de
transport intermédiaire à tous les
maillons de la chaîne et par ailleurs
alimenter des villes de 10 millions
d'habitants ça ne fait pas sans pétrole
non plus alors je reviens aux villes
quelque chose qu'on note de manière
absolument spectaculaire donc là aussi
j'ai pas mes graphiques favori pour vous
le montrer mais croyez moi sur facture
ces essais et c'est très logique à cause
de la puissance des engins des
auxiliaires qu'on a aujourd'hui dans
l'agriculture il ya une loi du genre qui
s'occupe ap ce qui s'observe pardon
absolument partout dans le monde
aujourd'hui c'est que plus vous rentrez
d'énergie dans un pays - ya des gens
dans les champs ça marche extrêmement
bien géré gars j'ai constaté ça
absolument partout la raison encore une
fois est logique comme la surface
cultivable n'augmente pas quand vous
amener de l'énergie mais que par contre
la productivité des agriculteurs
augmente de manière faramineuses
eh bien vous êtes capable de libérer des
paires de bras qui vont pouvoir faire
autre chose alors cet autre chose
s'exerce ou dans les villes mais il se
trouve qu'avec plein d'énergie c'est
parfait vous pouvez aussi alimenter les
villes avec des transport longue
distance donc retenu également quelque
chose qui est absolument capital c'est
que l'urbanisation et le fait de
l'abondance énergétique souvent au début
enfin quand j'ai quand j'ai commencé à
m'intéresser à l'énergie je pensais que
la bonne manière de traiter les villes
c'était de les rendre danse pour que les
gens en face tout à pied et en
trottinette électrique et que comme ça
on allait être sauvées en fait non
la bonne manière de gérer les villes
aujourd'hui c'est de les faire dégonfler
c'est à dire que 10 millions de
personnes en ile de france que ce soit
dans souhaité aller c'est pas la
question c'est de toute façon pas
vivable dans un monde en contraction
énergétique n'est pas vivable du tout
les villes donc l'apparition des villes
c'est le fait de l'abondance énergétique
et on le voit très bien encore une fois
avec l'évolution vous avez dans tous les
pays qui sont en ce moment en train
d'accéder à l'énergie à vitesse
accélérée quand vous regardez la chine
quand vous regardez l'inde etc tous ces
pays s'urbanise pour la même raison à
chaque fois c'est à dire que l'énergie
permet d'amener des auxiliaires aux
agriculteurs avant les tracteurs
s'étaient l'écolier de trait et les
charrues 1
mais d'une manière générale ça permet
d'amener des auxiliaires aux
agriculteurs d'amener des transports à
laval qui sont commodes et c est ça
permet donc de mettre les gens dans les
villes les gens dans les villes vont
faire deux choses ils vont faire de
l'industrie enfin au début de
l'artisanat puis de l'industrie et des
services
et là aussi quelque chose qu'il faut
sortir de la tête c'est que beaucoup de
services c'est la marque d'une économie
dématérialisée en fait c'est l'exact
inverse
quand vous regardez dans le monde
quelles sont les émissions de co2 par
personne en fonction de la fraction des
services dans l'activité
vous vous rendez compte que c'est
parfaitement corrélés positivement
dit autrement plus les émissions de co2
par personne sont élevés plus la
fraction de service dans l'emploi est
élevé aussi c'est logique
qu'est ce que les services s'est
organisé le monde du jardin parce que pu
le dire
organiser le monde pour organiser le
monde vous avez besoin de beaucoup de
gens si le monde est compliquée avec des
tas de flux dans tous les sens mais pour
que le monde soit compliqué avec des tas
de flux dans tous les sens c'est que
vous avez plein de machines qui sont en
train de vous créer plein de flux donc
si vous avez un monde sous perfusion
d'énergie inversement dans un monde dans
lequel il ya pas beaucoup d'énergie vous
avez pas besoin de beaucoup de services
alors je vais prendre un exemple tout
con qui est la voiture
imaginons que je n'ai plus l'énergie
pour construire et faire avancer les
voitures j'ai plus besoin de banquier
pour financer du crédit auto dehors
c'est les services j'ai plus besoin
d'assurer rothau d'or c'est des services
j'ai plus besoin de moniteur d'auto
école et monitrices dehors c'est les
services j'ai plus besoin d'agent de
circulation c'est dans la rue dehors
mais plus besoin de personne pour
encaisser bonne nouvelle pour vous enfin
bref vous voyez qu'il ya tout un tas de
profession dans cette affaire sans
parler de tous les employés du ministère
des transports qui régule qui font la
sécurité routière et c'est donc tout ce
pan de services disparaît et à la limite
j'ai même plus besoin des médecins qui
sont aussi dans les services pour
soigner les accidents de la route donc
vous voyez bien que sur la base d'un
flux industriels qui est celui de la
fabrication de voitures
en fait j'ai empilé tout un tas de
services quand je vais prendre un autre
exemple qui est cet amphi nous sommes
ici dans un lieu où on enseigne
on ne dira l'enseignement c'est
totalement dématérialisée ouais sauf que
qui ici n'a besoin jamais d'aucun moyen
de transport pour se rendre dans cet
amphi dans la semaine voilà donc tous
les autres ils ont besoin d'un bout de
métal qui s'appelle un transport tous et
qui est tout à fait le résultat d'un
produit industriel qui dans cette salle
n'a pas d'ordinateur
à part moi dans le mien est tombé en
rade la chute ce qui peut la suite qui
peut lever la main fabriquer un
ordinateur c'est une demi tonne de co2
c'est des mines et de la métallurgie
c'est de la chimie c'est lé transport
intermédiaire c'est de l'industrie
manufacturière et c est aujourd'hui dans
l'enseignement sauf moi qui tente de
faire sans ce soir vous en avez besoin
vous portez tous des vêtements du reste
il est interdit de se balader tout nu en
france sauf m'a dit ma fille d'enfermer
mangeant pas plus loin
donc
vous avez besoin de vêtements même pour
venir en cours les besoins d'endettement
et bien ses vêtements ont été fabriqués
par une armée de machines d'accord entre
les machines qui était présente dans les
champs pour cultiver le coton et lin les
machines qui étaient présentes sur terre
pour extraire du pétrole parce que tous
les gens qui portent une fibre
synthétique ici porte du pétrole voilà
donc tous les trucs en poly machin
chouette le dit long et c'est tout ça
c'est du pétrole dont vous avez eu
besoin de plateformes pétrolières de
raffinerie de vapocraqueur de tréfileur
de métiers à tisser extrudeur etc enfin
bref vous avez une armée de machines qui
s'est mise avant faire de l'enseignement
sans que les gens puissent venir à poil
et sur plus en bâtiment qui est aussi le
produit de l'industrie en hiver quand il
flotte je pense que l'enseignement il ya
un peu moins de gens que ça intéresse
donc vous voyez bien que toutes les
activités même les activités dites de
services en fait dépendre de flux
industriels sous jacents et pour ceux
d'entre vous qui comme moi ont besoin de
lunettes enfin moi pour voir de près
certains d'entre vous pour voir de loin
c'est pareil c'est un produit industriel
d'accord donc pas de lunettes
l'enseignement c'est un peu plus
compliqué donc vous voyez bien que on a
en fait une la séparation entre services
et industrie est une séparation
totalement artificielle de même que la
séparation entre l'agriculture et le
reste une séparation artificielle aussi
parce que si on mange plus tout le reste
n'existe plus j'ai entendu quelques
économistes distingués m'expliquer que
l'agriculture c'était 2% du pib en
france n'est pas très grave si on en
avait moins
alors je me suis dit que si les premiers
à mourir de faim c'est les économistes
effectivement il avait raison le donc
donc ce que je ce que je viens d'essayer
de vous dire avec les mains c'est que
l'énergie c'est à dire les machines donc
partout vous entendrez énergie à partir
de maintenant vous barrer le mot et vous
remplacez par machine d'accord consommer
de plus en plus d'énergie c'est utiliser
de plus en plus de machines
c'est donc accroître la taille de notre
costume d'iron man c'est ça hein
utiliser de plus en plus d'énergie alors
ce costume vous l'avez pas sur vous un
le laminoir de fos sur mer vous le
portez pas sur votre dos en ce moment en
attendant vous bénéficier tous de ce
qu'il fait pour vous le donc l'énergie a
totalement façonner le monde qui nous
entoure et c'est notamment ça qui fait
que vous avez le temps d'étudier à
l'agro plutôt que de ramasser des
patates
je vais vous le dire encore autrement
dans l'ancien monde et avait le temps de
réfléchir
les rentiers donc c'est pas un hasard
que tous les grands scientifiques dia
trois siècles ou plus aient été des
rentiers c'étaient tous des barons
machin des comptes de bidules que des
rentiers pourquoi parce que c'était les
sols qui était détaché des contingences
quotidiennes qui était pas éreintés
après une journée passée dans les champs
et qui avait le temps de phosphorer un
peu aujourd'hui tous les employés de
bureau ils ont une activité de type
rentiers d'accord ils passent leurs
journées à phosphorer dégager des
contingences matérielles immédiate ils
n'ont pas besoin de tisser leurs
vêtements ils n'ont pas besoin etc et on
a reproduit le modèle de l'ancien temps
sauf que au lieu d'avoir des cerfs ou
des esclaves ou des paysans qui bossent
pour nous qu'on a des machines dans
l'ancien temps les démocratie athénienne
et romaine c'était une poignée de
citoyens libres assis sur une armée
d'esclaves
c'étaient les esclaves dans les
campagnes qui leur fournissaient leur
nourriture et bien les démocraties
modernes c'est pareil sauf que c'est une
poignée d'humains libre au milieu d'une
armée d'esclaves
cette armée elle est pas neutre parce
que si à l'instant où je vous parle vous
regardez quelle est la puissance du parc
de machines en fonctionnement sur terre
donc au moment où on se parle ya des tas
de machines qui sont en train de
fonctionner sur terre des laminoirs des
satellites des bateaux qui sont en train
d'avancer d'être acquis sont en train
d'avancer les camions qui sont en train
de rouler les chaudières qui sont en
train de chauffer et c est bien au
moment où je vous parle la puissance de
la totalité du parc de machines sur
terre qui est en train de fonctionner
c'est des centaines de fois la puissance
musculaire de l'humanité donc la
capacité productive des hommes grâce à
l'énergie a été multiplié par un facteur
de plusieurs centaines comparé à ce que
nous serions capables de faire avec nos
seules muscles c'est ça l'énergie c'est
ça les larges donc un débat citoyen sur
l'énergie moi je veux bien mais en fait
c'est un débat citoyen sur ce que nous
sommes
sur la totalité de ce que nous sommes et
penser que les débats sur l'énergie sont
des débats techniques où on va coller un
ingénieur dans un coin futile agro de
choisir entre une éolienne et un bout de
centrales nucléaires c'est avoir
totalement raté l'objet du débat
l'objet du débat c'est que l'énergie
c'est ce qui a fait de nous des
surhommes
alors l'énergie a donc alimenter
l'agriculture l'agriculture en retour de
temps en temps on se demande si elle ne
veut pas alimenter l'énergie notamment
au travers des cultures énergétiques
alors il se trouve que je sors tout
juste aux ateliers du shift d'un exposé
absolument passionnant qu'on va mettre
en ligne d'un chercheur du lied le
laboratoire interdisciplinaire des
énergies de demain qui se trouve sauf
erreur de ma part à paris 7
alors je vous donnerai pas son nom parce
qu'il a un nom grec imprononçable je me
rappelais juste qu'il y est barbu et
chevelu mais à part ça rien on va mettre
ça en ligne dans quelques dans quelques
semaines est en fait il a il a fait un
exposé qui montre magistralement que
l'agriculture dans un monde entre
guillemets renouvelables ne pourra pas
contribuer à la fourniture énergétique
des hommes elle pour aller nourrir
points c'est à dire une fois que vous
avez supprimé les engrais fossiles la
mécanisation fossiles y sud etc
vous ne pourrez pas sortir de la
biomasse en quantité massive pour faire
une chimie renouvelables une aciérie
renouvelables une industrie
renouvelables et une cimenterie
renouvelables d'accord les rangs demande
les rendements et le nombre de gens sur
terre n'autorise pas ça donc si on était
50 millions sur terre ça passerait
peut-être mais à quelques milliards ça
passera pas c'est intéressant comme
point de vue il ya un dernier point donc
de ce qui est maintenant la question du
climat donc l'agriculture bénéficie de
l'énergie mais l'agriculture impacte
également comme vous le savez le climat
alors dans l'agriculture un premier lien
avec le climat c'est que si on émet
moins de gaz à effet de serre avec moins
de mécanisation ça va impacter le
système agricole
si vous avez par exemple point de
transport de marchandises parce que vous
avez moins de pétrole
ça va nécessairement impacté le système
agricole c'est ce que je vous ai
expliqué tout à l'heure vous aurez
besoin d'aidé spécialisés les régions
agricoles pourraient pas faire toutes
les betteraves ici toutes les vaches là
toutes les céréales là et toutes les
pêches ici va falloir un peu plus mais
c'est exactement ce qu'on avait en
france la polyculture élevage avant
d'avoir les tracteurs et les engrais à
gogo c'est exactement ça qu'on avait et
c'est pas un mystère que l'on soit parti
dans l'autre sens
donc l'agriculture également un
contributeur au changement climatique
alors le changement climatique chevet
quelques bases je voulais dit tout à
l'heure le climat toujours varié
simplement les échelles de temps de
cette variation sont absolument capital
pour savoir si c'est quelque chose de
désagréable ou pas pour prendre un
parallèle tout de suite vous avez deux
manières de décélérer 200 km/heure à
zéro quand vous êtes en voiture
la première c'est d'appuyer sur la
[ __ ] de frein ça prend 10 secondes la
deuxième c'est de rentrer dans un mur ça
prend quelques millisecondes le résultat
n'est pas le même eh bien c'est
exactement pareil en ce qui concerne les
variations du climat le climat varie il
a toujours varié simplement pour les
variations qui sont en train d'être mise
en route en ce moment la question
cruciale est celle des échelles de temps
par rapport aux variations spontanée du
système le climat peut varier plein de
raisons historiquement au quaternaire la
première raison pour laquelle le climat
a varié c'est que le système solaire
n'est pas un ménage à deux très
pacifique mais un ménage à 10 donc très
turbulent et en particulier la terre est
soumise à la traction des grosses
planètes du système solaire jupiter et
saturne un peu moins uranus et neptune
est donc l'ellipse que la terre décrit
autour du soleil n'est pas une ellipse
régulière elle a des petites variations
au cours du temps et ses variations
c'est à la fois une variation
d'excentricité elle est plus ou moins
allongée et une variations de
l'inclinaison de l'axé de rotation de la
terre sur le plan de leurs beats et plus
ou moins inclinés est quelque chose que
vous allez comprendre tout de suite
c'est que si la que c'était parfaitement
perpendiculaire au plan d'orbites on
aurait jamais de saison l'insolation
serait la même tout au long de l'année
donc il aurait pas de saison plus lac
s'est inclinée sur le plan d'orbites
plus les saisons sont marqués cette
inclinaison est un des éléments qui
déterminent de manière capital l'entrée
ou pas en glaciation à leurs côtés
renaer il y en a d'autres mais celui-là
joue de manière très forte
donc le climat varie encore une fois et
ouvriers ce qui est en train de se
passer à l'entrepôt scène c'est à dire
aujourd'hui avec l'homme qui est devenu
un agent climatique c'est que l'homme
est en train de devenir la première
cause du mariage de variations du climat
à l'échelle du siècle
c'est ça qui est en jeu alors comment
est ce qu'on fait ça on fait ça en
augmentant à phénomène parfaitement
naturel qui est là depuis des milliards
d'années qui s'appelle l'effet de serre
l'effet de serre qui est un processus
qui a été identifié par fourier joseph
de son petit nom il ya deux siècles
maintenant enfin 1824 on y est presque
est un effet qui est dû au fait que vous
avez dans l'atmosphère des mots
kühl qui sont parfaitement transparente
au rayonnement solaire incident est
parfaitement opaque au rayonnement
infrarouge émis par la surface de la
terre
si vous avez fait un peu de rayonnement
du corps noir avant de rentrer ici vous
savez que le spectre d'émission d'un
corps dépend de sa température alors le
soleil qui a une température de surface
à civile kelvin nous envoie
essentiellement du visible et
l'infrarouge proche la terre qui a eu
une température de surface qui est
proche de 300 kelvin et mais
essentiellement des infrarouges
lointains et bien dans l'air vous avez
plein de gaz
tous les gars stries atomique ou plus en
gros qui sont des gaz qui intercepte les
infrarouges terrestre donc la lumière du
soleil enfin où le rayonnement solaire
avec les infrarouges visible pardon non
visibles parce l'infrarouge proche passe
à travers l'atmosphère
- la part qui réfléchit par les nuages
la glace etc est absorbée par le sol et
le sol lui en réponse émet des
infrarouges dans des grandes gammes de
fin d'année dans les longueurs d'onde
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus importante
c'est un frein rouges sont absorbés près
de la surface par les gaz à effet de
serre qui sont donc des opacifiant ou
infrarouge que l'atmosphère en petites
quantités comme le père magalas de
potassium opacifie l'eau quand vous en
mettez dans une baignoire à paris avec
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
nous augmentons l'opacité de
l'atmosphère au rayonnement infrarouge
émis par la terre
donc ce que nous allons faire c'est que
nous allons confier l'énergie près du
sol et de ce fait augmenter la
température des équilibres du sol mais
nous allons également corrélativement
refroidir la stratosphère parce qu'il ya
moins d'énergie qui peut aller être
absorbées moins de rayonnement qui peut
aller être observé dans la stratosphère
et ça ça vous explique tout de suite une
chose très simple soit dit en passant
c'est que si vous avez une température
près du sol qui augmente et une
température de la stratosphère qui
diminue vous augmentez le gradient de
température dans l'atmosphère et donc
vous augmenter la puissance convective
de tout ce qui convainc qd je passe ils
ont dit ça de tous les mouvements
convectifs dans l'atmosphère et donc les
orages les tornades les ouragans la
pompe aspirante devient plus puissante
donc c'est très logique que vous ayez
trouvé dans le dernier rapport du giec
que dans un monde qui se réchauffe la
puissance des ouragans va augmenter
c'est parfaitement normal c'est un truc
qui est attendu on se pose également la
question pour les orages et les tornades
comme je les dis juste avant ce
réchauffement climatique
il est donc provoqué par une
augmentation des gaz à effet de serre
dans l'atmosphère et c
à s'accumuler dans l'atmosphère
notamment le co2 pour une raison
chimiques de base c'est pas à vous que
je vais apprendre que le co2 est un
oxyde dioxyde de carbone s'est pas non
plus à vous que je vais apprendre que
vous ne pouvez pas le dissocier
chimiquement sans apport d'énergie
si vous tentez de faire pousser des
plantes dans un endroit dans un placard
pas éclairé ça marche pas bien
peut-être que vous avez fait
l'expérience c'est sûr que ça marche pas
donc la photosynthèse est un processus
endothermique vous avez besoin d'un
photon vous avez besoin d'un apport
d'énergie qui va vous dissocier la
molécule de co2 parce que la liaison est
très forte et d'une façon plus générale
tous les oxydes sur terre sont des
molécules très stable 1 tous les
minerais métalliques par exemple se
trouve sous forme d'oxydé lors que le
métal peut être oxydé donc les oxydes
étant des molécules très stable une fois
qu'on a mis du co2 dans l'atmosphère il
n'y a pas de processus chimiques
spontanée d'épuration c'est la raison
pour laquelle le co2 peut s'accumuler
dans l'atmosphère c'est qu'il n'y a pas
de processus chimiques d'épuration vous
avez deux processus d'épuration l'un et
physique
c'est une dissolution dans l'océan ça se
fait à la surface de contact et un
équilibrage de pression partielle
c'est un processus physiques et en plus
c'est un processus qui est ralenti quand
le climat se réchauffe parce que la
capacité du ce de l'oat 10 août du co2
diminuent quand l'eau se réchauffe
donc c'est un puits qui va s'affaiblir
avec le temps
voire même qui pourrait se renverser et
vous avez un deuxième processus
d'épuration gensous d'en parler donc
c'est la photosynthèse donc le co2
s'accumulent dans l'atmosphère est une
constante de temps qu'il faut garder en
mémoire parce que c'est absolument
cruciales pour le débat sur le
changement climatique
si demain matin on arrête les émissions
dans le monde demain matin on arrête les
émissions dans le monde et bien le
surplus de co2 que nous avons créé il
n'y en a que 60 % qui sera parti dans un
siècle il en restera encore 20% dans
mille ans et 10% dans des bilans dont
vous avez un processus fondamentalement
irréversible en ce qui concerne le
changement climatique c'est comme le
vieillissement
c'est fondamentalement irréversible je
peux pas me dire à mon âge ah bah merde
j'aurais pas dû faire league sera dû
faire l'agro ailleurs pris 7
je me retrouve à 18 ans et je change de
voie ça marche pas d'accord c'est ça
marche pas donc le changement climatique
c'est exactement pareil
à cause de cette constante de temps de
du temps de résidence d'un surplus de
co2 dans l'atmosphère
il n'existe pas de possibilité de remise
en état du système
c'est une notion qui n'existe pas dans
le débat sur le changement climatique
donc si un jour comme petit gibus on dit
si j'avais su j'aurais pas venu trop
tard est la seule garantie que nous
avons dans ce débat la sole en ce qui
concerne le changement climatique
c'est que si un jour l'expérience se met
à nous déplaire pour de bon la seule
garantie qu'on aura à ce moment là c'est
plus tard ce sera pire
c'est important d'avoir ça en pétain
c'est parce qu'on n'est pas du tout des
animaux câblé pour être capable de
réagir à ce genre de problème parce que
je vous rappelle et vous le savez à
toutes les mensuels
nous sommes des animaux nous sommes des
animaux alors si je suis un tout petit
peu plus sérieux nous sommes des animaux
c'est à dire que nous sommes gouvernés
par nos sens notre rapport à
l'environnement se fait au travers de
nos sens nous sommes innocents son court
termiste est instantané enfin immédiat
et enfin locaux et instantanée pardon
donc mes sens me permettent de dire
quelle est la température qui fait dans
cette pièce tout de suite mes sens ne
permettent absolument pas de dire quelle
est la température qui fait en australie
à l'instant où je vous parle
et encore moins la température qui
faisait anchois ou à vladivostok et six
mois d'accord mais sens ne me permettent
pas de dire sa cervelle oui c'est plus
compliqué mais sans ce nom dans tout ce
qui relève de la moyenne du et ses
terrasses et pas avec nos sens qu'on
peut l'approcher c'est avec une approche
intellectuelle mais on n'est pas fait
pour ça et par ailleurs le mode
d'apprentissage qui a été le nôtre comme
tous les animaux qui sont gouvernés par
leur sens et un vote et ses erreurs
alors le voit d'essais et erreurs
fonctionne très bien dans les situations
réversible sauf pour les quelques uns
qui font une erreur tellement grave qui
s'y passe voilà ça a toujours été le cas
dans tous les représentants d'une espèce
animale
de temps en temps il y en a qui font une
expérience qu'ils n'auraient pas dû
faire crac easypass les autres le wild
il ajouté pour faire la même chose mais
donc vous avez un apprentissage de type
essais erreurs mais quand vous n'avez
pas droit à l'erreur comment vous faites
parce que dans cette affaire là on aura
qu'un seul essai donc on n'aura pas
droit à l'erreur
enfin officiellement si on s'est trompé
perdu et c'est très très difficile ça a
l'air de rien dit comme ça mais c'est
très très difficile de lutter contre ses
sens et de faire prévaloir la partie
gauche ou droite je sais jamais de sa
cervelle c'est à dire celle qui vous a
permis de rentrer ici très difficile
donc le changement climatique est un
phénomène à très très forte inertie
alors pour vous donner quelques ordres
de grandeur sur ce que ça veut dire ce
changement climatique le premier ordre
de grandeur qu'il faut avoir en tête
c'est que 5 degrés que vous avez
évidemment en tête comme étant la
fourchette haute
pas maintenant on parle de 6 à 7 mai du
réchauffement climatique
en fait c'est la même chose que ce qui
correspond à une transition glaciaires
et interglaciaires donc quand la france
est passée d'un paysage qui ressemblait
au nord de la sibérie
il ya vingt mille ans à l'état qu'on lui
connaissait
dans l'ère préindustrielle et en presque
encore maintenant il ya dix mille ans eh
bien le climat ne se réchauffe et que
2,5 degrés sur la planète donc 5 degrés
en un siècle
c'est un réchauffement 100 fois plus
rapide que celui qui a vu l'océan
remontée de 120 mètres en dix mille ans
les écosystèmes devenir ce qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui alors qu'ils étaient ceux du
nord de la sibérie et une calotte de
glace de trois kilomètres d'épaisseur
posé sur la scandinavie et le canada
disparaître 5° en divisant donc 5 degrés
en un siècle c'est évidemment quelque
chose c'est un chaos c'est un choc
extrêmement violent
alors dans les évolutions qualitatives
auquel il faut s'attendre
d'abord il faut savoir que la
température va pas monter de manière
homogène l'inertie thermique des
continents et en plus faible elle
montera plus vite sur les continents que
sur les océans donc si vous avez un
réchauffement global de 2 degrés ce sera
3 sur les continents ensuite ça va pas
être vrai également pour les extreme iii
sur les continents ça veut dire 5 à 6
pour les extrêmes
donc c'est pas du tout proportionnelle
cette affaire là la deuxième chose qu'il
faut savoir c'est que le réchauffement
climatique va globalement augmenté
l'évaporation donc augmenter les
précipitations
par contre la science la plus moderne
permet de dire deux choses c'est que ça
sera encore plus mal répartie qu'avant
c'est à dire ceux qui en ont beaucoup en
or ou encore plus et ceux qui en ont pas
beaucoup en auront encore moins et donc
dans ceux qui n'ont pas beaucoup qui en
auront encore moins le pourtour du
bassin méditerranéen va s'assécher joue
cia qu'on est dedans donc nous on est du
mauvais côté de la barrière dans cette
histoire les anglais vont se faire et
non des plus souvent les scandinaves
aussi et la mousson sera plus violente
mais une mousson plus violentes sur des
sols plus sec
ça sera pas nécessairement très
intéressant pour les cultures indiennes
le lundi ce de sécheresse des sols va
augmenter dans nombre de zones et
notamment en france donc on a toutes les
chances en france d'ici 2050
c'est-à-dire quand vous aurez mon âge
que la sécheresse que nous ayons connu
cet été soit l'état moyen des sols en
france ça peut être terrible ça peut
être terrible j'en vois un qui lève le
sourcil ça va pas être terrible
il est évident que dans ce genre de
paysage une bonne partie des forêts
disparaissent parce que nous avons
aujourd'hui des arbres qui ont quand
même un peu besoin d'eau qui aime pas
trop quand il fait trop sec quand même
pas trop quand il fait trop chaud
et quel patron les incendies non plus et
par exemple en 2050 la capacité de la
forêt de fontainebleau a développé des
incendies sera la même que celle des
landes aujourd'hui dans les autres
joyeusetés auquel il faut s'attendre
l'océan va monter à l'océan va monter
pour deux raisons la première c'est que
quand vous chauffez l'ol se dilate et
donc si vous chauffer l'eau qui est dans
une grande baignoire sans toucher au
fond est bien le niveau de l'eau monte
mais c'est pas ça qui va faire le plus
monter l'eau ce qui va faire le plus
monter l'eau c'est l'atteinte aux
calotte polaire alors le groenland a
commencé à fondre
dès à présent et à partir de maintenant
vous n'avez que des rétroactions
positives qui vont amplifier la chose
la première rétroaction positive c'est
que comme vous le lisez probablement
dans la presse l'étendue de la banquise
a tendance à diminuer de plus en plus or
quand la banquise disparaît vous
remplacez une surface très
réfléchissante par une surface très
absorbante pour le rayonnement solaire
et donc la température qui environnent
la calotte groenlandaise a tendance à
s'élever encore plus vite
la deuxième chose c'est que la fonte de
la calotte est une fonte de surface
c'est pas des icebergs qui se déversent
dans la mer pour l'essentiel c'est une
faune de surface après l'antarctique de
l'ouest y autre chose j'en parlerai
comme c'est une fonte de surface quand
le niveau
quant à fond le niveau de la calotte
enfin l'altitude maximale de la calotte
baisse un peu et du coup vous vous
rapprochez d'un air ambiant qui est un
peu plus chaud puisque quand vous
descendez en altitude
vous savez que cause de la détente est
diabétique la température augmente et
donc la température environnante
augmente
dernier point la surface du groenland et
couverte de poussière qui sont amenés
par le vent quand vous êtes dans un
processus dans lequel vous avez
accumulation annuel de poussière mais de
neige qui recouvre la poussière c'est
pas grave mais quand la neige se met à
fondre
à ce moment les poussières sont
concentrés en surface et elle augmente
aussi d'albédo c'est à dire la capacité
d'absorption du rayonnement solaire de
la calotte donc bien que de rétroaction
positive dans cette affaire donc d'ici à
ce que l'humanité s'éteignent enfin non
quelques siècles le groenland va
continuer à fondre et ça c'est n'importe
quoi entre 3 et 6 mètres d'eau dans
l'océan
quelques siècles de l'autre côté il ya
une instabilité majeur qui a été mise en
lumière par l'a6 la communauté
scientifique ya maintenant quelques
années qui est celle de l'antarctique de
l'ouest alors l'antarctique de l'ouest
il ya pas de l'ouest en antarctique
puisque c'est centré sur le pôle sud
normalement l'antarctique de l'ouest
c'est la partie de l'antarctique qui
regardent le chili qui est en face du
cap horn vous savez avec cette espèce de
grand douala qui remonte vers le vers le
chili c'est une partie qui est détaché
de l'antarctique de l'est par 2 1 dans
passion qui sont les mer de ross et
devait d'elle et elle porte cette
antarctique de l'ouest une calotte qui
est posée sur un socle rocheux est
totalement sous marin en déclivité
et c'est un vaste système de glaciers en
arcs boutants les uns sur les autres les
arcs-boutants terminaux c'est les
glaciers qui se déverse dans la mer
alors tant que ces glaciers qui se
déversent dans la mer se déversent pas
trop vite ils jouent leur rôle d'arc
boutons par rapport aux glaciers qui
sont au dessus
à partir du moment où ces glaciers qui
se déversent dans la mer se déverse
beaucoup plus vite et c'est ce qui est
en train de leur arrivée en ce moment
les arcs-boutants finaux sont
fragilisées et tout peut s'écrouler
comme un château de cartes
en combien de temps il ya trois ans il
ya un papier qui a fait grand bruit qui
est sorti dans sa liane ce qu'ils
disaient en quelques siècles
dès qu'on a passé 2 degrés donc dès que
le réchauffement dépasse
dès que la terre est sur une trajectoire
de réchauffement qui dépasse les 2
degrés en 2100 ce qu'on est évidemment
partie pour faire et bien le risque de
déstabilisation existe et la science la
plus récente dit maintenant quelques
siècles on sait pas ça peut être plus
court que çà et là il y en a pour six
mètres dos donc 6 + 3 plus la dilatation
on est en train de jouer en ce moment
donc ça va pas arriver la semaine
prochaine mais
le doigt sur la gâchette s'est tout de
suite on est en train de jouer en ce
moment avec dix mètres dos en plus dans
l'océan mondial 10 mètres dos en plus
vous n'avez plus une ville côtière vous
avez plus enfin si vous avez des villes
côtières surélevé donc si vous êtes en
haut de la montagne où il ya là
la bonne mère notre dame de la garde à
marseille vous n'êtes pas inondée mais
il ya plus un port donc c'est parfait
les routes maritimes seront ouvertes
parce qu'ils habitent banquise il ya
plus de ports pour partir et arriver
posera un petit problème
vous avez énormément d'installation qui
sont situés en bord de mer et vous avez
évidemment ce que vous savez énormément
de plaine alluviale qui sont des
endroits majeur pour l'alimentation
humaine
le delta du nil le delta du gange enfin
je vous en passe et des meilleures donc
tout ça et bien avant que ça fasse dix
mètres ça sera salini zay à cause de la
pression osmotique parce que quand la
mer monte sa valise les nappes
phréatiques qui sont situées en dessous
toujours dans les joyeusetés vous allez
avoir une pression supplémentaire sur
les écosystèmes et enfin il faut bien
voir que la première pression sur les
écosystèmes ces 8 milliards de bons à
main de très très loin parce que la
première pression sur les écosystèmes et
la biodiversité c'est la perte d'habitat
est la première cause de perte d'habitat
c'est la suppression des écosystèmes
installé pour faire des cultures donc on
a deux problèmes si on aime bien la
biodiversité qui s'appelle la taille de
la population et son régime alimentaire
donc on a deux sujets de préoccupation
si on aime bien la biodiversité qui
s'appelle le planning familial et manger
moins de viande
c'est à peu près ça le les déterminants
de la faire le toujours dans les
conséquences vous allez évidemment avoir
après des conséquences sociales et
politiques à large échelle alors dans le
dernier rapport du giec changement
climatique et terre qu'il a lu ici vous
êtes tous virés vous êtes à l'agro il
faisait pas du ca scandale non mais je
plaisante pas d'un chic maison mais
quand même c'est un scandale
si vous avez une lecture à avoir dans
l'école dans laquelle vous êtes c'est
celui là c'est celle là pardon donc
lisez le résumé pour décideurs
changement climatique et hertz a fait 35
pages vous devriez y arriver c'est
vraiment un truc absolument crucial
compte tenu du de la filière qui est la
vôtre absolument crucial
donc dans le dernier rapport du giec
changement climatique et heures
le giec 10 à partir de 3 4 degrés de
réchauffement il ya des de l'insécurité
alimentaire généralisée sur la planète
alors vous vous rappelez peut-être de
est ce que vous savez ce qui s'est passé
en 1788 à ça c'est bien vous savez un
demi million à un million de morts
vous avez entendu parler du printemps
arabe est ce que vous savez ce qui s'est
passé juste avant inflation alimentaire
intolérable c'est ça qui s'est passé
juste avant dans des pays qui sont en
insuffisance alimentaire locale c'est
des pays qui sont obligés d'apporter
leur nourriture
l'égypte la tunisie 1 et ça va en
augmentant parce que le bassin
méditerranéen ça sèche alors que leur
population croît et les importations
agricoles ont des prix qui varient très
largement comme ceux du pétrole en 2010
très forte remontée des prix du pétrole
donc les pays qui importent de la
nourriture voient leur facture
alimentaire augmente et mai 2010 on est
dans l'after maaf 2 1 de la crise de
2009 et donc les touristes restent chez
eux donc les recettes à l'exportation de
ces pays l'egypte et la tunisie se sont
cassé la gueule moins de recettes plus
de charges on n'est pas capable de
compenser budgétairement enfin de
compenser le prix de la nourriture pour
les gens qui sont dans les trois quatre
cinq premiers déciles de revenus qui
vivent avec un dollar par jour et c'est
l'émeute
parce que ils ont fait quoi s'acheter à
manger et en fait des émeutes de la faim
au moment où le prix du pétrole est
repassé par des sommets vous en avez eu
dans plein d'endroits dans le monde
alors aujourd'hui on est encore avec une
agriculture très productive des
combustibles fossiles de partout des
engrais de partout et c'est tout ça
n'est pas éternel il est évident que
quand vous aurez une agriculture avec
des sols plus sec et des intrants en
quantités moins disponible avec une
population censé être plus nombreuses
oui on est d'accord on lève le sorcier
du deuxième fois c'est pas complètement
sûr que tout ça va être
un long fleuve tranquille et donc il ya
également des instabilités politiques
qui sont à la clé et donc dans les
risques du réchauffement climatique vous
en avez aussi un qui s'appelle la
dictature et même en france
mais en france la démocratie en france
c'est récent pendant les milliers
d'années que notre pays a hébergé des
hommes
il s'est passé un siècle en démocratie
d'accord donc c'est court et c'est pas
éternel je suis pas en train de dire que
je souhaite sa disparition juste en
train de dire c'est pas éternelle parce
que c'est un système fragile et c'est
notamment un système fragile parce que
c'est un système qu'on termiste pendant
qu'il a dit c'est monsieur taux d'il ya
deux siècles il s'était pas trop trompé
donc voilà donc le changement climatique
c'est un processus à large échelle
l'insécurité sur l'approvisionnement
énergétique c'est aussi un processus à
large échelle
je vais finir par ça dans cette
affaire-là donc à ce stade vous avez
compris plusieurs choses si on a été
capable de mettre tout le monde en ville
avec une agriculture très productive
c'est grâce à l'énergie
cette énergie fait que on a été capable
de monter à 8 milliards d'hommes bien
nourris raisonnablement sauf quelques
endroits sur terre parce que justement
on a été capable de rendre l'agriculture
beaucoup plus productive alors que la
terre n'a pas augmenté de diamètre fait
toujours la même surface qu'il ya la
dérive des continents n'a pas fait
apparaître une quantité de surfaces
cultivables supplémentaires majeur en
deux siècles
vous comprenez également qu'on a un tout
petit sujet avec l'instabilité
climatique alors l'agriculture contribue
soit dit en passant au réchauffement
climatique puisque dans les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre à peu près un tiers
si je prend en compte la déforestation
vient du secteur agricole dans les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
concernés vous les trouvez dans la
déforestation
c'est 10% sur 30% et le reste c'est les
émissions voleuse l'émanation plus
exactement de méthane des rizières
vous savez que dans les rizières vous
avez de la décomposition anaérobie de
résidus organiques à l'abri de l'oxygène
de l'air ça vous fait du méthane
comme dans les marécages c'est la
fermentation entérique des bovins les
cochons quatre estomacs dégueulasse
sauf quand on en fait des tripes et
c'est les déjections animales pour
partie et enfin c'est la réduction des
nitrates qui s'opèrent quand vous
épandez des engrais azotés dans les
champs et chivu produit un gaz qui
s'appelle le n2o du protoxyde d azote
qui est aussi le gascon vous est
peut-être fait respirer quand vous étiez
gamin à l'hôpital le gaz hilarant qui
est un anésthésiant léger donc
l'agriculture au travers de toutes ces
émissions là contribuent au
réchauffement climatique et les
émissions directes du secteur agricole
c'est pas pour cent des émissions de gaz
à effet de serre c'est autant que les
centrales à charbon dans le monde donc
c'est pas complètement négligeable
c'est peut-être moins comment dire c'est
peut-être plus indispensable que les
centrales à charbon soit dit en passant
mais c'est quand même 20% donc
l'agriculture un lien avec l'énergie et
le changement climatique qui est
extrêmement intime un sa productivité
vient de l'énergie le fait qu'on ait pu
mettre les gens bien nourris dans les
villes c'est l'énergie l'agriculture
contribue au changement climatique et le
changement climatique
en retour va faire du mal à
l'agriculture globalement donc voilà le
paysage dans lequel on est et comme j'ai
pas de slide je m'arrête là
donc maintenant passe aux questions et
la bonne question évidemment c'est
qu'est ce qu'on fait c'est ce qu'on fait
voilà merci au revoir
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'on fait alors la première
chose qu'on fait c'est qu'on dit aux
gens que la nourriture va coûter plus
cher
est ce que vous savez par combien a été
divisé le prix de la nourriture en
occident sur un siècle
4 vous êtes très en dessous plutôt entre
10 et 30
alors petit raisonnement en 1930 alors
je vous donne ça pour les américains
parce que alors je suis désolé de dire
du mal des français mais quand vous
voulez trouver une série longue sur le
site de l'insee vous mettez un quart
d'heure a pas trouvé ce que vous vouliez
alors que quand vous allez chez les
américains en deux clics de souris vous
trouvez donc je suis désolé je vais vous
le dire pour les américains mais c'est
pareil en ce qui concerne les français
en 1930
madame michu et monsieur michu dépenses
pour se nourrir un quart de ce qu'ils
gagnent 1 car c'est déjà beaucoup moins
qu'en 1800 ou comme je vous le disais
tout à l'heure vous aviez un agriculteur
qui pouvait nourrir une virgule cinq
personnes ce qui revenait à dire que
monsieur et madame michu dépensait les
deux tiers de ce qu'ils gagnaient dans
la nourriture médoc en 1930 mais en 1800
je suis désolé le linde équivalent
américain de l'insee 1930 donc monsieur
madame michu dépenses 25%
qu'est ce que c'est à l'époque que
l'alimentation monsieur et madame michu
alors je suis désolé de te dire ces
propos sexistes dans une école à
dominante féminine mais je vais les
tenir quand même donc c'est
essentiellement en madame michu qui va
acheter aux paysans d'à côté ou au
marché local des produits bruts des
poireaux des oeufs du poulet des pommes
de terre etc et qui fait le frichti pour
monsieur michu qui par auchan ou à l
usine
c'est ça la façon dont l'alimentation se
présente
vous avez un peu de restauration hors
domicile
mais à l'époque ces quelques pourcents
de ce que les gens gagner évidemment
c'est très inégalement réparti ses 0
chez le paysan et ses 80 % enfin c'est
100% du temps chez monsieur rockefeller
qui est mort du christ à cette époque là
donc ils mangent que des vers de terre
naturelle en 2000 en fête 2010
l'alimentation de monsieur et madame
michu leur coûte 10 % de ce qu'il gagne
alors effectivement la première bonne
réponse avant une réponse que j'ai
entendu la bonne ça a été divisé par
deux et demi mais en fait pas du tout
quand vous passez la caisse d'un magasin
que je ne nommerai pas là vous allez à
machin market histoire de pas dire
qu'ils aient machin dans la rue d'à côté
et vous sortez avec votre ticket de
caisse
l'insee dit c'est une dépense
alimentaire mais qu'est ce que vous avez
acheté en vérité vous avez acheté des
boîtes en carton vous avez acheté le
salaire de la caissière vous avez acheté
le salaire du magasinier vous avez
acheté le salaire du conducteur de
camion qui vous a amené la marchandise
vous avez acheté le salaire des ouvriers
qui ont mis les pattes dans les boîtes
de pâtes
vous avez acheté etc vous avez acheté
tout sauf la nourriture que vous allez
manger alors un exemple tout con ça
normalement devrait connaître la réponse
quel est le prix d'une boîte de
dégueulasse pas bio au supermarché ah je
vois que c'est cela que vous achetez
c'est pas bien
c'était un piège un euro cinquante aller
est ce que vous savez quel est le prix
de l'offre en sortie de fermat chez
l'éleveur intensif breton à bravo
combien font siffler trois fois 6 c'est
bien vous suivez 18 centimes
les zéros transformation on les a pas
cuit on les a pas lâchés on les a pas
rien juste les autres on les a mis dans
une boîte 1 euro 50
d'accord vous êtes passés de 20 centimes
pour un ordre de grandeur un euro 40 un
ordre de grandeur x 7 vous n'avez
acheter que autre chose que des e mails
insee vous dit votre ticket de caisse
c'est votre dépenses alimentaires
alors je vous dis non votre dépenses
alimentaires c'est 10 % de votre ticket
de caisse d'accord donc le ticket de
caisse aujourd'hui pour la partie achats
de nourriture qui représente 5 % des
dépenses des ménages
en fait c'est pas 5% que vous coûte
l'alimentation c'est 1% maintenant
imaginez parce que vous êtes des csp +
que vous en avez marre d'acheter les au
supermarché vous allez manger une
omelette au café d'en face il paraît que
le café d'en face et fameux pour ses
obsèques
j'ai eu l'information je tiens de
première main eux et donc vous avez
compris ce que vous avez payé votre
omelette au café d'en face
ouais 5,6 euros 6 euros
donc voilà il ya combien d'eau dans une
omelette trois accords
donc je suis à dix huit sentiers 20
centimes pour un truc qui vous allez
payer 5 euros et l'insee mais aussi la
restauration hors domicile dans la
nourriture
donc là je dis moi ça vaut rien et ça
vaut pas c'est ça quelques pourcents de
ce que vous dépensez en moyenne 1 5%
message dit ça ça vaut zéro donc on est
passé de 25% qui était vraiment de
l'alimentation totale eat et de
l'alimentation à 1 à 2% qui représentent
la part de la nourriture dans le ticket
de caisse que vous allez laisser au
magasin donc là je suis bien à une
division par 20 et en plus par rapport
au elle américain alors l'américain chez
pas mais le français de 1930 vous manger
trois fois plus de viande
donc le prix de la protéine animale lui
il n'a pas été dicté par d'un il a étayé
par 60
donc la première chose qu'il faut dire
aux gens
qu'est ce qu'on fait c'est qu'ils vont
payer plus cher pour manger moins de
viande s'il ya d'autres questions
ou si vous avez soif et voulait dire non
et d'autres questions quand même aha si
je savais alors je vais je vais être un
peu provocateur je pense que les chinois
ont un système qui est plus proche de
quelque chose qui permet de gérer le
long terme que nous mais c'est un peu
coopératif d'une manière générale
l'exercice parfait de la liberté
individuelle suppose une absence de
limites puisque ça suppose que tout ce
que vous allez pouvoir faire en plus ne
gênera pas l'aptitude des autres
affaires également quelque chose en plus
donc ça ne peut s'appliquer que dans un
monde en croissance c'est à dire dans un
monde sans limite
et soit dit en passant si je reviens à
ce que je disais tout à l'heure
aucun système contre 1,1 de l'ancien
monde n'était démocratique la démocratie
athénienne et romaine c'est une illusion
parce que ça s'appliquait à tous toute
petite partie de l'élite
c'était l'élite ce qui était
démocratique très bien mais la masse de
l'été absolument pas donc tous les
systèmes du monde contraint de l'ancien
temps sont des systèmes dictatoriaux ou
assimilé ces s'appelait la monarchie
absolue
alors est ce que c'est ça qu'il faut
souhaiter je ne sais pas
est ce que c'est ça qui nous pend au nez
dans un monde dans lequel on ne gère pas
la contrainte de la meilleure manière
possible en sachant suis certain est ce
qu'on arrive maintenant à trouver un
système mixte qui permet de gérer
collectivement la contrainte en la
trouvant supportable peut-être soit dit
en passant il ya aussi un truc est très
intéressant et que tocqueville avait
bien pointé du doigt dans les système
monarchique anciens les gens n'étaient
pas nécessairement plus malheureux
qu'aujourd'hui bien que plus limité
parce qu'ils étaient fatalistes
car ils considéraient que leurs
conditions de naissance étaient leurs
conditions normales et qui avait pas
envie et les nobles parce que de toute
façon c'était un truc était pas fait
pour eux qu'ils ne le serai jamais et
que c'est comme vous vous enviez pas la
condition de l'arbre parce que
manifestement vous serez jamais un arbre
quoi
eh bien eh bien c'est exactement ça le
fasse était beaucoup plus répandue dans
le dans la population
mais c'est clair que ça pose le problème
de sa pose le problème pardon delà du
système pertinent et alors il ya au
moins une chose contre laquelle on peut
essayer de lutter tout en restant dans
un monde démocratique c'est ce que
j'essaye de faire un vin modeste échelle
c'est d'avoir une population qui
finissent par être suffisamment informés
pour dire j'accepte la contrainte donc
quand est ce que vous l'avez été
intelligemment en place c'est ce qu'on a
eu avec le tabac par exemple c'est à
dire que à force de comprendre que le
tabac ce n'est pas terrible
la population dans son ensemble accepte
la contrainte est par exemple dans cet
amphi il est aujourd'hui interdit de
fumer je pense qu'il ya 50 ou 60 ans
n'était pas le cas en tout cas moi j'ai
connu des salles de classe où ils
étaient autorisées de fumée pour
l'enseignant donc c'est ce qui peut vous
paraître très étonnant à juste titre
donc le et j'ai connu des compartiments
fumeurs dans les trains j'ai connu des
compartiments fumeurs en avion il sait
pas bien de prendre l'avion etc
voilà j'ai connu j'ai connu tout ça il
faut arriver exactement la même chose
quelque part en ce qui concerne cette
affaire là c'est à dire qu'il faut
arriver à comprendre où sont les limites
arriver à comprendre comment est-ce
qu'on peut les gérer de la manière la
moins douloureuse possible ou la plus
enthousiaste possible et à ce moment
réclamer ou dire qu'on est d'accord avec
la contrainte
alors si c'est utopiste de penser qu'on
va informer tout le monde c'est
absolument évident c'est aussi tout
aussi coûteux piste de penser que tout
le monde va passer entre les gouttes 1
ça me paraît évident que il va y avoir
des des épisodes douloureux mais quelque
part plus on procrastine et plus ça va
être douloureux donc je suis sûr que
dans cette salle vous connaissez toutes
et tous scott attenberg c'est votre
génération et ella discours qui de mon
point de vue est parfaitement fondées
c'est à dire dire y'en a marre que vous
procrastiner sait parfaitement fondées
vous avez aussi évidemment entendu
puisque je crois que là gros et le plus
fort taux de signataires parler du
manifeste étudiants pour un réveil
écologique je connais moi alors moi je
connais bien une partie des initiateurs
parce que chez vous mais ailleurs c'est
également quelque chose qui est un
facteur de pression très utile donc
continuer qui est un facteur de pression
sur les gens de ma génération
parce que vous êtes nos enfants quoi
donc on écoute un peu 1-2 fonctionner je
répondis je reconduis sur cette question
ça marche ceci ça marche vous entends
très bien j'ai du mal avec les micros je
venais sur cette question de l'éducation
est ce que vous travaillez avec carbone
qu'à tout autre route de aux fonctions
avec le juge sur une déviation nationale
pour essayer d'intégrer ça dans un
programme niveau collège lycée le plus
tôt étant le mieux
alors on a commencé par le on a commencé
par la cible la plus facile qui est
l'enseignement supérieur
c'est la cible la plus facile pour deux
raisons la première c'est que la
décision de modification des programmes
dans un établissement d'enseignement
supérieur est une décision qui relève de
l'établissement donc si demain matin la
direction de l'agro décide que il change
les cours à la grosse ça dépend de la
direction de l'agro voilà donc c'est
relativement facile à faire la deuxième
raison pour laquelle on s'est attaqué
d'abord à l'enseignement supérieur
c'est parce que le niveau de maturité
qu'il faut pour comprendre les notions
dont je viens de parler à l'instant
facilite la simulation quand je veux
dire plus on est âgé et qu'on a déjà
compris un certain nombre de choses plus
c'est facile de parler de ce problème
qui est un problème de système
d'optimisation sous contrainte et de
limites c'est des trucs qui sont plus
compliqués à faire comprendre à des gens
qui sont plus jeunes
donc les gens qui sont plus jeunes la
tentation va être très grande de leur
donner 3 recettes de moulinette à
tourner alors que le la chose
véritablement importante c'est de
comprendre pourquoi on en est arrivé là
de comprendre l'imbrication systémique
de la faire j'ai pas fini et de
comprendre le qu'est ce que veut dire le
lait les voies les voies et moyens et
les contreparties dévoisé moyens
l'enseignement secondaire à un double
inconvénient pour nous c'est un mammouth
comme disait l'autre
le changer les programmes dans
l'enseignement secondaire il faut passer
par trois ans de négociations aux deux
en grève et je sais pas quoi donc on
n'est pas rendu vous avez un sujet de
formation des enseignants ou de
modification de l'enseignement qui est
beaucoup plus compliqué moi il sauf que
j'enseigne aux mines
je suis arrivé au mincom vacataires
c'est à dire que le directeur des études
m'a dit un jour tiens j'ai envie d'un
cours sur le sujet on obtient ici tu
fais un coup dur et je me suis dit moi
même si ça le processus de sélection des
profs rallye donc mais oui c'est ça a
été ça le processus de sélection des
profs donc le don donc c'est une
décision qui est très rapide à prendre
et si demain matin ils pensent que la
biodiversité c'est beaucoup plus
importante l'énergie et le changement
climatique inédit jancovici on a assez
vu et l'année d'après ils prennent un
vacataire pour faire autre chose donc
c'est très simple dans ces
établissements de se débarrasser des
enseignants dont on veut plus parce
qu'il enseigne un truc qui vous
intéressent pas dans l'éducation
nationale c'est un peu plus compliqué
donc tout ça pour dire que au shift
comme on a une petite équipe
la réponse est oui on s'y attaquer et
parue dans le jdd dans le journal du
dimanche
il ya très exactement une semaine
plus ou moins trois jours 1 une tribune
signée de 80 dirigeants d'établissements
d'enseignement supérieur alors je vous
le dire parce que dernier à signer a été
le président de l'x l'avant dernier a dû
être le président de l'agglo enfin
directeur de l'hérault mais c'est pas
grave il a signé quand même et donc les
grands sont toujours prier mais encore
une fois le président dit que c'était le
dernier
là il ya 80 dirigeants d'établissements
qui ont donc signé une tribune en disant
on va faire des choses chez nous et on
sent on demande à l'état de nous
faciliter la vie est dure et je rebondis
sur l'histoire du manifeste donc
maintenant qu'il a signé sa votre
directeur comme 2 et fédérale faute et
lui la pression
[Rires]
le l'enseignement secondaire ça va être
long et lent ça viendra aussi avec des
enseignants les enseignants du
secondaire sont formés dans le supérieur
donc c'est pour ça pour toutes ces
raisons on a choisi de démarrer par le
supérieur est encore une fois on est dix
on n'est pas 500 sinon on n'aurait pas
dit autre chose mais où pour rebondir
sur ce que je disais sur le secondaire
est ce qu'il ya vraiment besoin c'est un
peu un peu peu ambitieux mais ce qui a
vraiment besoin d'expliquer le problème
au secondaire je prends comme exemple
pendant longtemps il ya une
sensibilisation autour de l'utilisation
de l'eau par exemple de l'utilisation de
l'électricité on n'a jamais expliqué aux
enfants pourquoi si ce n'est si ce n'est
que c'était bien ou pas bien c'est ce
que je disais tout à l'heure c'est à
dire que sensibilisation avec trois
recettes presse bouton ça a pas beaucoup
de valeur
ce qui a de la valeur c'est d'éveiller
les consciences et d'éveiller les
éveiller les esprits et de faire
comprendre comment ça marche alors sur
ce genre de truc c'est très compliqué
par contre vous pouvez quand même ne pas
leur apprendre des âneries je suis sûr
que l'on voit la fonction d'utilité en
économie dès le secondaire on peut
supprimer sur des programmes ça ne pose
aucun problème au contraire ça rendra
les gens plus intelligents donc le don
qu'il ya des aménagements dans le sens
de la suppression qui sont des
aménagements qui peuvent parfaitement
être fait quand même un jeu mais c'est
sûr que c'est si peu de valeur dans la
mesure en question ça il y avait plein
de main alors oui il ya un billet
classique dans ce genre de truc c'est
qu'on attend ça se limiter à son champ
visuel alors moi je sais que j'ai vu
plein de main se lever au fond là depuis
un moment et moelleux mon champ visuel
de vac lardons qu'il a âprement de
l'autre côté aussi
je voulais revenir sur ce que vous venez
de dire par rapport au manifeste
étudiants quand vous dites continuer de
faire pression
c'est très utile est ce que vous pensez
pas que dans une optique où on demande
quand même de la décroissance quand on a
fini de faire le tour des questions
énergétiques
ça fait vraiment sens de s'adresser
notamment à des organismes privés qui
sont croissance souvent n'existerait
plus alors vous pouvez demander deux
choses qui j'ai envie de dire non pas
besoin de statuer sur la question que
vous venez de me poser la première c'est
vous pouvez demander à ce que les
programmes incluent de manière
croissante une capacité à comprendre les
sujets dont je viens de parler ça veut
dire des programmes qui incluent de
manière croissante la vision system la
compréhension de l'interdépendance du
système agricole avec ailleurs et qui
vous permet de voir un peu loin et qui
vous permet de comprendre qu'une société
comme danone quoi qu'elle en dise elle
n'a pas d'avenir dans un monde sans
pétrole
parce que vous n'avez pas de possibilité
d'avoir une multinationale de cent mille
personnes qui collecte de lait partout
avec des camions qui fabrique des
yaourts dans quelques usines centralisée
qui distribue partout dans des
supermarchés dans lesquelles les gens
ont besoin d'aller en voiture etc
ça ne marche pas ça vous empêche pas
d'aller chez eux mais juste vous savez
où vous mettez les pieds et j'ai rien
contre danone
il ya des gens très gentils très
sympathique qui voit là mais c'est juste
pour dire la structure elle-même
vous comprenez bien qu'elle ait
fortement instable les deux choses que
vous pouvez faire donc c'est demandé à
ce que l'enseignement s'enrichissent et
le manifestent à cette utilité aussi je
le sais pour l'icg ce qui a fait bouger
le président d' x c'est le fait que les
étudiants si le manifeste et commence à
dire c'est un sujet qui nous importe
donc le simple fait de le dire fait que
derrière l'enseignement deviendra plus
riches sur ce qui vous permet de mieux
comprendre le problème et si vous avez
envie de vous en occuper
l'enseignant je suis aussi pense que
c'est pas idiot que vous le comprenez
mieux
la deuxième chose que qui a un effet
évident c'est que ça déplace le temps
que va y consacrer l'état major d'un
certain nombre de grandes entreprises
alors je sais pas si c'est le cas à
l'agro mais je peux vous dire comines la
part des jeunes diplômés qui part dans
les grands groupes a chuté de moitié
entre 2013 et 2017
moitié dort pas en train de parler d'une
variation marginal moitié je sais pas si
c'est en lien avec le sujet que j'évoque
cela étant depuis 2013 moi je les ai
tous eus donc je sais pas si c'est un
lien est ce que je raconte mais une
chose est sûre c'est que il ya des
modifications de comportement et ça a un
effet ça suffira pas probablement pour
sauver le monde mais ça a un effet
positif qui est que vous savez tant
qu'il n'y a pas une entreprise 10 nov
que sous la contrainte
c'est bien je suis chef d'entreprise
donc ce qui fait bouger une entreprise
c'est la contrainte de la concurrence
l'a contraint qui déplace les envies de
ses clients la contrainte de ses
salariés notamment ceux qu'elle a envie
de garder qui lui disent si tu fais des
trucs qui me déplaisent moi je vais
aller voir ailleurs le temps qui fait la
contrainte de la puissance publique et
de la réglementation et c'est donc ce
qui fait bouger une entreprise ça n'est
que des contraintes d'accord pour
qu'entre les entreprises disent ne nous
était pas de contrainte ça n'a pas de
sens si vous voulez qu'elle bouge il en
faut une il faut la bonne est par contre
il enfouit donc le manifeste est une
contrainte ça dit mais oui ça dit si
vous voulez qu'on vient de bosser chez
vous faites au moins semblant de vous
intéresser à la question c'est le nom je
peux vous assurer que moi j'ai quelques
clients à carbone 4 alors ils sont pas
en train de faire la révolution encore
que mais il ya eu un phénomène discret
entre il ya un an et aujourd'hui et je
pense que le manifeste joue là dedans je
dis pas que c'est 100 % de ce qui s'est
passé je pense que ça joue là dedans je
pense que greta d'une berge joue là
dedans c'est à dire que tous les
dirigeants ils ont des enfants de votre
âge donc il ya probablement quelques
discussions de temps en temps qui sont
devenus un peu plus animée c'est sûr non
mais c'est absolument certain donc cessé
et on le voit bien du reste aujourd'hui
les réactions qui a vis-à-vis de cette
personne sont des réactions à côté de la
plaque puisque au lieu de juger le
message on juge le messager s'en fout du
messager
jeudi elle a le mérite d'exister enfin
ce qui est intéressant c'est de
l'écouter ce qu'elle raconte est ce
qu'elle raconte c'est des conneries ou
pas des conneries message est on s'en
fout son histoire personnelle et par
ailleurs touchant mais c'est pas le
messager qui compte c'est le message
donc le donc se manifeste il fait
remonter le bruit aux oreilles des
entreprises de la puissance publique qui
peut donc se dire ah bah si je colle une
contrainte aux entreprises
il ya un certain nombre de gens qui vont
pas s'arrêter de voter pour moi et ces
gens sont par ailleurs des prescripteurs
d'opinion parce que vous vous apprêtez à
faire partie des corps intermédiaires
qui sont des prescripteurs d'opinion
bah oui donc
donc voilà maintenant pour répondre à la
question qui est est ce que les
entreprises vont militer alors que vont
nous recruter alors qu'on visite pour la
décroissance
la réponse est oui pour certaines parce
qu'il ya certaines entreprises qui vont
profiter de la décroissance
si aujourd'hui vous êtes une amap en
vente directe vous profitez de la
décroissance
parce que vous permettez à vos clients
d'acheter en direct avec tous les
intermédiaires qui ont disparu d'accord
donc ou bien vous achetez de l'amap pas
bio en général ils font quand même bio
mais est à ce moment vous payez moins
cher qu'au supermarché ou bien vous
achetez à la map bio est à ce moment
vous payer le même prix qu'au marché je
sais pas ce que j'ai fait les
comparaisons partout qu'au supermarché
pardon je voulais j'ai regardé donc pas
tellement différent donc le là vous avez
des gens qui vont bénéficier de la
contraction globale du système
le fait qu'ils aient moins de camions
pour transporter va bénéficier à ces
gens là si le gaz vaut plus cher les
gens qui vendent de la laine de verre
pour isoler les combles font de
meilleures affaires
donc vous avez est en fait c'est ces
gens là qui nous intéresse au schiste
soit dit en passant parce que comme je
suis un grand cynique à l'âge que j'ai
j'ai parfaitement compris qu'on ne
faisait pas avancer une cause sans
s'appuyer sur les gens à qui elles
bénéficient eh bien les gens à qui ça
bénéficie cette affaire-là c'est les
gens qui vont profiter de l'évolution
globale du système et vous savez une une
contraction s'est pas une suppression
donc même si le système productif est
divisé par 2 ou 3 il reste encore
quelque chose
il ya plein de gens qui sont prêts à
jouer pour faire partie de quelque chose
donc c'est voilà donc ce n'est pas la
disparition de doute
de toutes les activités c'est ça se
focalise mais je le redis l'effet à
court terme c'est que il ya un certain
nombre de gens qu'ils -o
il faudrait que je commence à regarder
ça pour revenir sur le sujet de
l'agriculture et l'énergie pour vous
c'est quoi un modèle agricole dans
lequel il ya une contraction sur
l'énergie ça ressemble à quoi
alors c'est un modèle qui disposera
d'une plus grande difficulté à avoir un
débouché à val important enfin
géographiquement large de ces produits
donc ça veut dire que vous devrez
trouver votre zone de chalandise plus
près avec moins d'étapes de
transformation donc je disais tout à
l'heure le maïs parce c'est un
transformateurs d'aliments qui passe
chez le cochon qui passe lui même dans
une découpe dans un abattoir qui passe
dans une découpe industriels qui passent
chez paou qui passe au supermarché qui
frappe en bref donc ça ça se raccourcir
à c'est une agriculture qui sera plus
sobre en gros animaux parce qu'elle sera
nécessairement moins productive parce
que ce qui aujourd'hui permet de rendre
les cultures très productive c'est le
fait qu'on ait explosé de cycle de
l'azoté
c'est le fait que vous ameniez des
amendements de synthèse en grande
quantité si vous avez juste les
amendements des animaux qui ont été
faites dans les champs ça suffit pas
c'est une agriculture avec des
exploitations qui sont globalement plus
diversifiée c'est une agriculture dans
laquelle vous récupérez des services
écosystémiques qui avant vous
débarrasser d'une partie des maladies et
des ravageurs c'est à dire les oiseaux
la compétition intrinsèque et c'est donc
avec des enfants ou des endroits où il
ya des bestioles qui puisse se mettre
parce que ça vous mangerez avouent
manger une partie des prédateurs
c'est une agriculture dont comme je
disais tout à l'heure les produits en
sorties vont valoir plus cher
nécessairement voilà donc celle inverse
de ce qu'on a fait depuis que on a mis
des combustibles fossiles dans
l'agriculture c'est à dire plus
spécialisés plus exportatrice plus
productives
c'est exactement l'inversé de ça je suis
pas en train de vous dire que ça arrive
en une semaine
par contre je ne crois que marginalement
au fait qu'on va avoir des tracteurs
autonome robotisée qui vont vous bouffez
l'équipement se nourrir avec les limaces
qui bouffe dans les champs et ses parts
d'ombrés juste pour finir et c'est une
agriculture qui réintègre de la force de
travail je suis totalement convaincu du
fait que le monde dématérialisé à cause
de ce que je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
c'est pas des employés de bureau qui
ressorte le soir avec le pli du pantalon
impeccable le grand paradoxe est qu une
économie plus dématérialisé est une
économie dans laquelle il ya plus de
travail manuel vous avez parlé de la
contraction énergétique en jeu 10 ans
nathan
qu'est ce que vous voyez comme solution
vous avez parlé de l'éolienne du
nucléaire comment est-ce que vous alors
j'ai déjà commencé se marre vous
rappeler qu'elle est déjà là en europe
cette contraction énergétique l'énergie
que nous utilisons aujourd'hui dans le
monde est à 80% constitué de
combustibles fossiles
les combustibles fossiles pour bien leur
nom puisque c'est des restes fossilisés
de vie ancienne la manière dont le
pétrole et le gaz se sont constitués si
vous avez du planton et des micros agde
qui ont fait des résidus organiques
mélangé à du sédiment minérale près des
côtes en général par la tectonique des
plaques ce truc là est enfoui sous le
sol
et là j'étais un niveau cuissard vous
distille sa petit feu jusqu'au moment où
ça vous exsude du gaz et du pétrole qui
vont dans les bons cas de figure se
concentrer dans des roches poreuses qui
sont situés au dessus il faut 50 à 400
millions d'années pour que ça se passe
donc c'est un peu long pour ce soir
renouvelables
le charbon c'est les fougères qui ont
poussé à l'ère du charbon au carbonifère
donc il ya quelques centaines de
millions d'années 300 si ma mémoire est
bonne qui se sont fossilisés avec le
même processus et qui donne aujourd'hui
les veines de charbon 80% c'est de la
propagande de l'approvisionnement
énergétique c'est des combustibles
fossiles
le fait de passer à autre
alors pardon ces combustibles fossiles
sont épuisables d'accord comice
renouvelle en 50 à 400 millions d'années
la vitesse à laquelle on tape dedans
leur permet pas de se reconstituer et là
vous avez un petit et aurèle de maths
qui vous dit quand vous tapez dans un
stock de départ qui peut pas se
reconstituer
l'extraction de votre stock suis un
bicorne de polytechniciens là sa part de
zéro ça passe par un maximum et ça
repart à zéro c'est vrai et soit dit en
passant pour le pétrole et le gaz mais
c'est vrai pour le minerai de cuivre et
c'est vrai pour l'argent d'accord tout
ce qu'on peut sortir de la croûte
terrestre qui n'est pas renouvelable
aura un pic à son extraction annuel
nécessité mathématiques il se trouve
qu'en ce qui concerne le pétrole dits
conventionnels
c'est à dire tout ce qui n'est pas le
pétrole de roche-mère le pétrole et le
gaz qui restaient prisonniers dans la
roche mère qui l'a vu naître avant de
migrer vers une roche réservoir et tout
ce qui n'est pas les sables bitumineux
c'est à dire ce qu'on a au canada et qui
est du vieux pétrole qui a migré en
surface qui a perdu ses éléments
volatils dans un dans une roche qui
était du sable donc ça vous fait une du
sable mélangé à du bitume et bien tout
ce qui n'est pas les sables bitumineux
et le pétrole de roche-mère la
production mondiale à décline depuis
2008 qui en avait déjà entendu parler
vous êtes beaucoup mieux informé que la
population ne peuvent française et
pourtant toutes les mains d'oeuvre est
levée c'est le déclencheur directe de la
crise des subprimes c'est le déclencheur
directe de la crise des subprimes j'ai
pas mes graphiques aujourd'hui pour vous
le montrer mais
j'ai des enregistrements vidéo sur
internet vous irez voir la démonstration
dessus en basse résolution donc bah oui
finances a fait trop de pollution
numérique donc le le pétrole
conventionnel dans le monde décline
depuis 2008 alors le pétrole non
conventionnel pour le moment il fait
plus que compenser le déclin mais dans
ce non conventionnel on a du mal à
savoir ce qu'il ya exactement parce que
vous avez du vrai pétrole vous avez du
faux pétrole des liquides de gaz etc
donc c'est un peu difficile d'y
retrouver ses petits l'alimentation
européen en pétrole décline depuis 2006
donc de 2006 à 2014 se décline de 2014 à
2018 c'est reparti dans l'autre sens
c'est la raison pour laquelle hollande a
vu la courbe du chômage s'est inversée
sur la fin de son mandat et macron a vu
la courbe du chômage s'inverser sur le
début de son mandat il ni l'un ni
l'autre n'y sont pour quoi que ce soit
c'est juste que l'approvisionnement
européen en pétrole est reparti dans
l'autre sens et c'est aussi la raison
pour laquelle les émissions de co2 des
transports sont partis dans l'autre sens
même cause deux effets différents donc
l'europe déclinant pétrole depuis 2006
et ça va recommencer à s'inverser
d'emploi le l'approvisionnement européen
en gaz décline depuis 2005 à l'époque en
2005 60 % du gaz européen vient de la
mer du nord qui a passé son pic en 2005
donc depuis l'approvisionnement européen
en gaz décline l'approvisionnement
européen en charbon décline depuis au
moins 1980 donc bien avant les sujets de
changements climatiques parce que ça
fait deux siècles comptable dans les
mines de charbon en europe et donc le
déclin géologique enfin le début du
déclin géologique est passé depuis
longtemps
1914 je crois en grande bretagne 10 950
je crois en allemagne enfin bon voilà
donc c'est il ya longtemps que c'est
passé charbon pétrole et gaz font aussi
80% de l'approvisionnement énergétique
européen aussi et soit dit en passant
pour l'énergie qui rentre dans les
machines en france les combustibles
fossiles vont les trois quarts donc vous
avez tous lu dans le journal qu'on était
un pays tout nucléaire non on est un
pays à dominante nucléaire dans
l'électricité mais si je regarde toutes
les machines qui fonctionnent en france
trois quart de l'énergie qui les
alimentent parce que dans ces machines
ya aussi des voitures des camions des
trois-quarts de l'énergie qui les
alimentent ces des combustibles fossiles
en france aussi donc l'approvisionnement
européen en charbon décline
l'approvisionnement européen en gaz
décline l'approvisionnement européen en
paix trident
troll pardon décline et comme zéro plus
zéro ça fait toujours la tête à toto
l'approvisionnement énergétique européen
décline donc nous la contraction
énergétique
on y est déjà d'accord est en fait toute
la zone ocde il ya déjà le japon il ya
aussi la même les états unis ils sont
d'une certaine manière et c'est ça qui
explique le marasme économique dans ces
pays n'arrive pas à sortir malgré les
inondations de milliers de milliards par
la banque centrale
et malgré tout ce qu'on peut mettre
comme petit trou dans le droit social
pour essayer de faire en sorte que les
gens bossent pour moins cher
malgré tout ça le truc continue à être
plein marasme dans cette affaire là que
peuvent les sources non fossiles alors
dans les sources non fossiles vous en
avez 2 vous avez les énergies
renouvelables et le nucléaire
alors en fait je devrais dire les
nucléaire parce que plusieurs manières
d'exploiter l'énergie nucléaire n'a pas
qu'une l'une comme l'autre ont quand
même un peu besoin quand même des
énergies fossiles
les énergies renouvelables ont besoin
des énergies fossiles parce qu'il faut
fabriquer le collecteur de l'énergie
renouvelable
il faut fabriquer le barrage 6 et de
l'hydroélectricité fabriquer la
chaudière
si c'est une chaudière à bois et pour
celles qui viennent à l'esprit de tout
le monde aujourd'hui c'est à dire les
éoliennes et les panneaux solaires
eh bien il faut de l'énergie fossile
pour faire la métallurgie et la chimie
qui vont permettre de fabriquer des
panneaux et des éoliennes
et soit dit en passant il faut beaucoup
plus de métallurgie pour faire des
éoliennes et des panneaux solaires que
pour faire des modes traditionnels de
production électrique parce que vous
avez 50 fois plus de métal nécessaires
pour produire un kilowattheure éolien ou
solaire que vous n'en avez besoin pour
faire un kilowatt heure avec une
centrale à gaz à charbon ou même
nucléaire donc vous avez des besoins en
métaux qui sont considérablement accrues
et en fait c'est ce qui fait dire à des
gens comme moi que de déployer des
énergies type éoliens ou solaires pour
pallier les énergies fossiles
butera sur une autre limite physique qui
est le besoin en ressources métallique
et du coup ça va se traduire
économiquement par le fait que les
investissements nécessaires sont
absolument faramineux
l'allemagne a déjà vu quelques centaines
de milliards d'euros quelques centaines
de milliards d'euros dans ces éoliennes
et ses panneaux solaires un ça lui a pas
permis de se débarrasser des centrales
préexistantes
conserve pour quand il ya pas assez de
soleil ou passer devant donc elle a
gardé les centres afin alors un peu
moins nucléaires un peu plus de gaz mais
en gros elle a gardé les centrales
prédit centre et elle a rajouté deux par
dessus des éoliennes et des panneaux
solaires pour quelques centaines de
milliards d'euros ça que marginalement
au baisser les émissions allemandes
donc c'est un truc qui va demander des
dizaines de milliers de milliards
d'euros avant qu'on en voit le bout
donc on va pas y arriver avec le solaire
et l'éolien le nucléaire on va pas y
arriver non plus dans les temps impartis
alors déjà c'est une très mauvaise idée
de s'en séparer alors y en a déjà
donc je fais partie des gens qui pensent
que de s'en séparer en france la
dernière des conneries à faire qu'on a
plusieurs gens beaucoup plus urgents
inférieur
le jeu peut revenir sur les dangers du
nucléaire ça vous intéresse mais j'étais
venu faire une conférence là dessus ici
qui doit être filmé quelques années donc
vous pouvez ressortir les archives et
puis l'autre
l'inconvénient majeur du nucléaire c'est
que c'est un système lent c'est à dire
quand le blog entre le moment où vous
donner le top départ et le moment où
vous avez une série de centrales qui est
disponible il faut compter 20 à 30 ans
la construction en version crash
programme des centrales en france qui a
démarré dans les années 70 elle s'est
terminée en 1990 quelque chose donc
et c'était en version crash programme un
truc qu'on serait plus capable de faire
politiquement aujourd'hui c'est à dire
que quand il ya eu le dialogue entre le
président d'edf à l'époque qui
s'appelait marcel boiteux qui ne l'est
pas du tout question aux cervelles je
peux vous assurer et le premier ministre
de l'époque était pierre messmer je me
rappelle enfin boiteux bladi dont je me
rappelle très bien mais sa mère lui dit
monsieur le président combien ce que
vous pouvez faire deux réacteurs par an
si vraiment je vous demande de pousser
tous les boulons tous les tous les feux
à fond boiteux réfléchit lui dis bon
aller au maximum maximorum je peux en
faire six et messmer de lui répondre
très bien vous montrer cette aujourd'hui
on n'imagine pas macron dix ans à lévis
vous allez me faire sept réacteurs
vous allez de démarrer sept réacteurs
par an quoique ce qui se passe lafreux
produc les airs machin c'était vraiment
qu'en plus ces dlc parfaire ce que
parfaitement vrai aujourd'hui
ils sauront refaire aujourd'hui donc le
donc c'est un système qui est lent c'est
juste c'est sale c'est ça le problème
donc là où il y en a fallu garder là où
on peut le développer faut évidemment le
développer parce que ça allège la peine
sur le reste
quand donc ça fait partie des parachutes
ventraux on va dire c'est beaucoup plus
économe en métal et en espace que les
nouvelles énergies renouvelables là
aussi il faut 1000 fois plus d'espacé
pour faire du solaire que pour faire du
nucléaire la production équivalente donc
vous avez un petit sujet avec le solaire
c'est qu'aujourd'hui pour déployer pour
déployer les badauds on est obligé de
bouffer sur des surfaces agricoles et
sur des forêts avec ce que je viens de
vous raconter je pense que c'est pas une
bonne idée donc le donc vous avez des
besoins importants
les deux seules énergies renouvelables
dans le monde pour finir là-dessus
qu'ils ont qui continue à jouer un rôle
important c'est la biomasse et
l'hydroélectricité et donc c'est des
énergies pour lesquelles vous avez de la
chance vous en avez pas dit autrement si
vous êtes dans un pays dans lesquels il
ya plein de forêt par habitant est plein
de montagne par habitant j'ai nommé la
suède alors là vous pouvez vous pouvez y
pensez donc 9 million d'habitants sur
les deux tiers de la surface française
70 % de forêts et des barrages à gogo
la suède peut rêver d'un monde quasi
industrielle avec des dernières des
énergies renouvelables elle peut en
rêver nous c'est pas possible
la belgique encore moins non mais ils
sont un peu plus densément peuplées que
nous et les pays-bas non plus donc le et
l'europe dans son ensemble non plus donc
il faut plus de montagne ou plein de
open forêt pour avoir des énergies
renouvelables c'est une affaire d'
espace essentiellement absolument en
france je vais jusqu'à dire qu'il faut
tout de suite arrêter les éoliennes et
les panneaux solaires qu'on n'aurait
jamais dû démarrer les énergies
renouvelables contentons finances il
faut mais on aurait aussi dû ne pas
faire iter parce que la fusion est un
truc que vous serez mort que ça aura
toujours pas démarré à une échelle
industrielle
donc vous savez quand alors j'aurais
quand même dû donner l'échelle de temps
pour se limiter aux 2 degrés s'il faudra
que je vous dis ça pour se limiter aux 2
degrés de réchauffement est ce que vous
savez par combien il faut diviser les
émissions planétaires d'ici à ce que
vous ayez même pas mon âge
d'ici à 2050 par trois ou par cinq sa
serait mieux c'est plutôt un degré et
demi par trois donc il faut les diviser
par trois en trente ans alors maintenant
je vais vous donner un autre chiffre
il n'y a pas de futur banquiers j'espère
dans cette salle mais si vous étiez
futur banquiers une direction sait faire
ça pour vous quand l'ordinateur marche
une division par trois en trente ans et
moins quatre et demi pour cent par an il
ya deux années au xxème siècle 2 pas 3 2
où les émissions de co2 ont baissé de
plus de 4% dans l'année ce que vous
pouvez le deviner
pas 1980 pas du tout non je crois que
j'ai entendu la bonne réponse ambroix
pas soixante dix alors 29 ans 145 bien
l'année de l'éradication industrielle de
l'allemagne et du japon
voilà ça ça fait moins 4% dans l'année
l'autre année où on a eu ça c'est le
paroxysme de la crise de 29
en l'occurrence était en 32 donc il
faudrait faire ça tous les ans à partir
de maintenant tous les ans à partir de
maintenant pour tenir les deux degrés on
fait pas ça tous les ans à partir de
maintenant l'antarctique se désagrège
choisis ton camp camarade
comme disait l'autre et oui c'est ça
c'est ça le sait ça le deal donc je
comprends la question qui a été posée
tout à l'heure est ce que le manifeste
va etc
j'en sais rien mais en tout cas ça peut
pas faire de mal le voilà donc le dos
est-ce qu'en france dans ce genre de
contexte
avec ce que je crois être le danger du
réchauffement climatique et du sevrage
non non anticipée des énergies fossiles
est à lire en gros la guerre partout est
ce que dans cette affaire la remplaçait
du nucléaire par des éoliennes me paraît
être le premier endroit où on doit
mettre nos milliards à l'évidence non à
l'évidence pour vous donner deux ordres
de grandeur est-ce que vous ça alors là
au moment où je vous parle en fait plus
exactement à fin 2010 8 le contribuable
français via l'état s'est engagé à payer
100 milliards d'un peu plus de 100
milliards d'euros 120 au producteur
d'électricité éolienne et solaire pour
les contrats qui ont été conclus avant
décembre 2018 donc dit autrement tous
les propriétaires d'installations qui
avant le 31 décembre 2018 avait mis
leurs installations avec contractualiser
avec l'état en disant je vais faire ce
truc là où j'ai déjà fait et je vends
mon d'électricité à tarif d'achat
garanti la somme de tous ces gens là va
encaisser 120 milliards d'euros d'impôts
120 milliard d'euros d'impôts
ces impôts viennent historiquement de
taxe sur l'électricité est maintenant de
taxes sur les carburants
donc les gilets jaunes sont très
contents de payer des taxes pour
construire des éoliennes qui vont
vachement les aider à se déplacer pour
moment ils s'en sont pas rendu compte
mais toujours il s'en rendront compte ce
n'est pas sûr qu'il soit ravi le avec le
tiers de cette somme
je supprime la totalité des chaudières
au fioul dans ce pays la totalité pour
les remplacer par des pompes à chaleur
dans le premier cas de figure je n'ai
pas baissé le co2 puisque le nucléaire
comme les éoliennes ça fait pas de co2
j'ai augmenté le risque nucléaire parce
que je vais garder mes centrale comme
les allemands ont gardé leur centrale
pour assurer la fourniture électrique
quand ya pas de vent je vais garder les
centrales françaises pour la fourniture
électrique quand ya pas de vent
simplement je vais moins m'en servir
dans l'année puisque quand il ya du vent
je m'en servirai pas donc elles vont
gagner moins d'argent que pensez vous
qu'il advient de l'entretien de quelque
chose qui a des coûts fixes et iliad
moins d'argent
je suis pas complètement sûr que ça va
contribuer à améliorer la sûreté
nucléaire
je suis même assez persuadé de l'
inverse donc on va dégrader la sûreté ne
rien faire sur le co2 et détruire de
l'emploi globalement parce que quand
vous faites un mégawatt heure nucléaire
dans ce pays vous importez un euro
d'uranium
quand vous faites un mégawatt heure
solaire comme c'est pas nous qui
fabriquons les nacelles ni nous qui
fabriquons les panneaux solaires les dix
premiers fabricants de panneaux
aujourd'hui sont chinois et les
fabricants d'éoliennes sont chinois ou
six ter que même quand vous achetez une
éolienne vestas ou siemens
maintenant la nacelle est fait en chine
l'usiné fait en chine donc vous
augmentez les importations donc vous
augmenter le risque nucléaire vous
augmentez les importations et vous ne
gagnez rien en co2 donc comme truc de
shadocks on fait pas mieux quoi donc
évidemment que c'est le premier truc que
j'arrêterai donc je m'occuperai des
chaudières à fuel des chaudières à gaz
de diminuer la taille des voitures et de
convertir tous les agriculteurs à
l'agriculture douce dont j'ai parlé tout
à l'heure parce que je suis sûr qu'avec
100 milliards je vais quelques petits
trucs dans ce pays donc et ça me paraît
beaucoup plus pertinent que le gouffre à
milliards qui a juste été la sucette
électorale que hollande a vendu au verre
donc il a vendu son droit d'aînesse pour
un plat de lentilles en l'occurrence en
droit d'aînesse c'est l elysée enfin
verse et le plat de lentilles c'était je
vais taper sur le nucléaire en
construisant des éoliennes mais c'est un
truc quand vous regarder objectivement
c'est un truc qui n'a strictement aucun
intérêt
je suis rien quelque part c'est la
meilleure preuve qu'on n'a pas compris
qu'il y avait un problème urgent il y
avait eu une main levée là depuis
longtemps il y en a une aussi là-bas et
puis je crois qu'un une là bas aussi qui
du coup vous avez soulevé un problème
qui n'avait pas été soulevée donc j'en
profite
vous avez dit qu'il ya un problème
d'approvisionnement et que c'est un
problème clé pourquoi est ce que le prix
arrive pas à réguler à un problème
d'approvisionnement
parce que dans les autre chose alors
vous avez appris un premier truc qui ne
sert à rien en économie qui s'appelle
l'utilité et il sert à rien parce qu'il
n'est confronte à bhl a aucune
expérience
je n'ai pas d'expérience ou en mesure d
utile et bien il ya un deuxième truc que
vous avez pris en économie qui est faux
qui est qu'il y a une élasticité prix
volume qui est persistante
alors en fait il n'ya pas d'élasticité
prix volume persistantes sur l'énergie
il ya une élasticité prix volume
instantané mais l epa persistante dans
les graphiques que je vous ai pas montré
mais vous pouvez le retrouver sur mon
site perso j'ai un article que j'ai
publié dans les haies dans les échos il
ya quelques années que j'ai reproduit
sur mon site perso qui s'appelle le
pétrole est-il élastique
en fait je parle évidemment du prix du
pétrole et à la suite j'ai vidé
graphique il ya un graphique que j'ai
fait dans lequel je regarde comment
varier le prix du pétrole en fonction de
la quantité qu'on peut acheter dans
l'année qui en fait la quantité produite
dans l'année et il n'y a strictement
aucune relation univoque entre les 2 0
ça ressemble à un bad boy
ce qui veut dire alors pourquoi c'est
comme ça parce que le pétrole est une
denrée essentielle au fonctionnement de
l'économie
en fait aujourd'hui le pétrole en volume
c'est le premier facteur limitant de
l'économie le premier il y en a pas deux
y en a qu'un c'est celui-là plus de
pétrole plus d'économies moins de
pétrole - d'économie c'est exactement
comme ça que ça marche que la fed fasse
ce qu'elle veut et que macro ont fait ce
qu'il veut sur les charges sociales
c'est juste comme ça que ça marche
le camp vous avez moins de pétrole
instantanément vous allez avoir une
hausse de prix donc la hausse de prix
existent l'élasticité existe à court
terme
mais si vous avez moins de pétrole vous
avez donc une économie qui peut vous
offrir moins de transport donc
l'économie produit - donc le pib des 106
le pib des sens comme le pib c'est la
somme des revenus les revenus de vos
consommateurs descendent donc l'offre de
pétrole est descendue mais les revenus
de vos consommateurs sont descendus
aussi est à ce moment vous avez un
nouveau prix d'équilibré qui n'a aucune
raison d'être au dessus du prix que vous
avez eue au moment du choc
et en fait il est en dessous par
ailleurs comme le pétrole est un facteur
limitant alors quand vous avez un choc
le prix du pétrole monte
du coup les producteurs de pétrole sont
incités à aller en chercher qui était
pas rentable avant donc l'offre devrait
un peu augmenter les conservateurs vont
faire un peu gaffe
d'abord parce que c'est la récession et
ensuite parce que le prix du pétrole est
monté donc ils vont en consommer un peu
moins du coup pas longtemps après vous
allez vous retrouver avec une offre un
peu en surplus à ce moment le prix se
casse la gueule
d'autant plus que le pouvoir d'achat de
votre consommateurs avait un peu diminué
à ce moment les producteurs de pétrole
se disent puisque le prix est bas je
vais pas aller en chercher du en plus
parce que c'est pas rentable
donc ils coupent dans leurs
investissements mais comme le prix est
descendu le consommateur se dit quand
même genre consommer un peu plus le cuir
descendu avec et avec le lait fait du
prix élevé précédant l'offre a été un
peu mieux approvisionné donc ils en
consomment un peu plus alors que les
investissements diminuent à ce moment la
production repart à la baisse la demande
repart à la hausse et boum et vous
recommencez de cycle donc en fait vous
allez avoir le prix du pétrole
la seule chose que vous êtes capable de
théoriser sur un approvisionnement
contre un c'est qu'il sera aussi y en
ait en fait ce qui va vous donner la
dureté de la contrainte c'est à mon avis
deux éléments un don je suis sûr
inquiétudes hypothèse mais l'avenir le
dira ce dont je suis sûr c'est que ceux
qui vont au delà contraintes sur la
disponibilité du pétrole c'est non pas
le prix de marché du pétrole c'est la
quantité d'investissement qu'il faut
mettre sur la table pour extraire un
baril jour supplémentaire et il se
trouve que le premier à m'avoir dit ça
aussi simplement c'est l'auteur de des
limites ce gros puisque j'ai eu
l'immense honneur dans ma vie de
rencontrer monsieur dennis meadows et il
m'avait dit exactement ça il m'avait dit
la rareté des ressources naturelles ne
se verra pas à travers leur prix de
marché
elle se verra à travers le fait qu'il
faudra mettre de plus en plus
d'investissements pour extraire une
unité supplémentaire de ressources et
quand vous regardez le pétrole c'est
très exactement ce qui se passe
le pétrole de schiste demande beaucoup
plus d'investissement par baril extrait
les sables bitumineux demande beaucoup
l'offshore profond demande beaucoup plus
d'investissement par baril extrait que
les grands gisements conventionnels à
terre sur lesquels les drones de chez
toi qui sont allés se faire la main et
pas longtemps ou le prix d'extraction
reste ridicule le puits d'extraction
dans ses gisements ses 5 dollars le
baril c'est 0 3 centime le kilowattheure
0,3 centime le kilowattheure de pétrole
avec la fonction de stock déjà incluse
le prix du kilowattheure éolien dans les
bons cas de figure c'est 4 à 5 centimes
sans la fonction de stock avec la
fonction de stock vous monte à 15 à 20
donc vous avez un rapport de 1 à 100
quasiment entre le pétrole qui attend
sous nos pieds gentiment qu'on vienne le
chercher et l'éolienne qu'il faut
construire en plus avec du pétrole déjà
sans pétrole ça serait encore plus cher
qui nous sort l'énergie du vent c'est à
dire 1 kg par mètre cube
[Musique]
donc le donc le voilà donc tout ça pour
dire que le prix n'est pas le marqueur
le marqueur c'est le capex par par unité
extraites et le deuxième marqueur à mon
avis ça sera la volatilité du prix quand
on était avant les premiers chocs
pétroliers
c'est à dire avec une offre pléthorique
le prix a été écartée lisez par les
producteurs il est resté stable pendant
un siècle quasiment après en dollars
constants il restait stable
harry les chocs pétroliers qui est le
début d'un homme d'une modification de
la dérive et sur l'offre de pétrole le
pétrole croissait de 8 à 9% par an il
qu'on ne croit plus que de 1% par an
après un gros changement dérivés à ce
moment là le prix commencent à aussi
alors il aussi avec une grande longueur
d'onde 10 15 ans premier choc en 1974 79
ça redescend deuxième choc dans les
années 90 ça redescend troisième choc
dans les années 2000 ça redescend ça
remonte plus vite 2008-2009 se casse la
gueule 2010 à remontent jusqu'en 2014
le cas ça se casse la gueule puis la
sarre commencé à remonter puis ça voilà
donc la longueur d'onde va se raccourcir
c'est ça c'est ça mon marqueurs pour moi
mais alors ça c'est une hypothèse que je
pourrais bien j'en ai pas la
démonstration formelle mais j'ai envie
de dire que le truc qui attire ma
vigilance à moi qui capte ma vision
c'est de regarder la longueur d'onde de
l'oscillation et plus elle se raccourcit
plus ça veut dire qu'on commence à avoir
une contrainte sérieuse sur le sur la
disponibilité
il y avait là je crois puis après il y
avait des malheureux de l'autre côté
bonjour je voulais vous demander ce que
vous pensiez alors moi je viens du nord
où on nous vend troisième révolution
industrielle
en ce moment avec les plans climat on en
vend biométhanisation partout où c'est
possible je sais pas ce que vous en
pensez et surtout quand vous me dites
y'a que la suède qui peut rêver d'un
monde industriel
est ce que nous on peut pas juste rêver
d'un monde paysan avec plein de sciences
avec de l'agro écologie etc
je pense qu'il va alors la donne la
réponse à la deuxième question est
facile je pense qu'il va falloir garder
l'élevage pardon la méthanisation qui
est fait dans la réponse à la deuxième
question c'est est ce qu'on peut pas
rêver d'un monde avec le paysan règles
etc
jeudi il va falloir donc c'est pas
tellement est-ce qu'on peut c'est qu'est
ce qu'on fait dans ce contexte là alors
avant de répondre à votre question mais
vous avez compris un peu touffu
je vais faire une incidente dans la
recherche aujourd'hui dans le monde
économique les sujets qu'on est en train
d'évoquer aujourd'hui n'existe pas c'est
à dire que les chercheurs du monde
économique payées avec mes impôts
il ya qu un seul truc qui sont en train
de regarder à quelques exceptions près
ça commence à changer un peu c'est
comment je suis revient la croissance
puisque la croissance et la baguette
magique qui règle tous les problèmes
il n'existe pas aujourd'hui dans le
monde économique de gens qui se penche
sur le vrai problème qui est le nôtre
c'est à dire comment est ce que je rêve
dans un monde contre 1 dit autrement
comment est-ce que j'optimise au mieux
ce que j'aurai où est ce que les gens
vont se sentir le mieux
qu'est ce qui est le moins qu est ce qu
elle perçue comme étant le moins et
inéquitable est ce que dans ce monde là
je dois enlever 40% ou s'avèrent de
sortie des agro
pour conserver le salaire des smicards
tout en leur disant c'est toujours bien
payé puis vous allez faire un truc qui
sera rigolo donc c'est pas si mal que ça
est ce que c'est ça que je sais pas mais
voyez il ya un
aujourd'hui ce débat là n'existent pas
du tout donc moi un truc que je commence
à dire par tous ces jeunes rien qu'avec
l'argent de mes impôts liés au moins 5 à
10% des économistes qui commence à
réfléchir à ça d'accord donc c'est une
digression sur la réponse à votre
deuxième question alors un monde
totalement paysans non il restera de
l'industrie de l'artisanat de la
réparation et c'est bon quand même des
acquis il ya eu connaissance du monde
qui nous entoure qu'on n'oubliera pas
c'est à dire le monde paysan de l'an mil
on savait pas que la terre était ronde
le fait de le savoir peut-être que quand
même c'est un peu mieux enfin toutes les
avancées scientifiques en a quand même
une partie qu'on peut conserver pour les
exploiter à notre profit juste vous avez
pas du tout parlé du labour biologique
ne sonnait pas et beaucoup d'énergie
oui aujourd'hui avec les bourguignons
qui parle de tout ça on arrive à faire
plus de production en comprenant le sol
en fait entre oui mais c'est évident que
c'est des choses qu'il faut faire donc
je le redis c'est un exercice
d'optimisation sous contrainte dans
lequel vous renverser le raisonnement
tient au lieu de vous dire la contrainte
je l'enlève par la technologie du
toujours plus là vous postulez que vous
n'aurez pas le toujours plus et vous
regardez où est ce que la technologie
c'est à dire l'application de la science
vous permet de faire mieux avec ce que
vous avez
en fonction des contreparties vous êtes
matar accepté c'est un exercice qui
demande beaucoup d'agilité
intellectuelle donc c'est enfin je veux
dire sur le plan strictement de la
réflexion c'est plutôt stimulant après
je vous placer mon rang couplet sur les
ingénieurs français donc dans parce que
je pense qu'on a intérêt nous a
enfourché son cheval de bataille des
premiers jeux vous placer tout de suite
en fait les ingénieurs français sont les
champions du monde de l'optimisation
sous contrainte
d'accord on sait pas tout faire dans le
monde on sait faire des sacs on sait
faire du champagne mais on sait faire de
l'optimisation sous contrainte on est
très très bon à ce jour là donc de se
dire il ya une énorme contrainte faut
qu'on s'implique dedans c'est au-delà du
fait d'être utile pour nous même utile
pour le service qu'on peut rendre aux
autres et donc et être utile dans le
monde de demain aura toujours une valeur
des changes d'accord donc je pense que
on a vraiment intérêt à foncer dessus au
moins autant par égoïsme bien pensé que
par empathie si on en a la deuxième
question
c'est le soliste riel troisième
révolution dossier les origines
bon alors j'écouterai monsieur rifkin le
jour où il fera une règle de trois alors
sinon qu'est ce que je pense de la
méthanisation
c'est pas nécessairement un truc idiot
je ne pense pas que ça c'est évident un
truc que des migrants un truc qui n'aura
jamais le potentiel de remplacer le gaz
qu'on utilise aujourd'hui pas une
seconde
l'essentiel du gaz qu'on utilise
aujourd'hui et dans le chauffage soit
dit en passant est supprimé le gaz dans
le chauffage c'est très simple je
remplace le chauffage par de l'isolation
contre le show et contre le froid parce
que vous avez peut-être constaté l'été
dernier que peut-être qu'une partie des
appartements parisiens vont devenir
invivable pour des raisons de chaleur
avant de devenir invivable pour des
raisons de froid donc enfin je sais pas
qui a mal dormi
l'été dernier il ya quand même
quelques-uns et vous faisiez partie des
chanceux qui étaient partis en vacances
ou en stage donc pour en revenir à ce
que je disais donc on va pas faire les
500 térawattheures de gaz qu'on consomme
aujourd'hui en france pas une seconde
mais il ya 60% de ce gaz qui est
consommé dans le chauffage celui là je
peux m'en débarrasser avec de
l'isolation et des pompes à chaleur est
un peu de bois exit le reste il ya une
partie qui va dans l'industrie et une
partie qui va dans l'électricité une
petite partie mon sentiment c'est que ça
ne sert strictement à rien de faire de
la métallisation pour faire de
l'électricité puisque comme je l'aï dit
tout à l'heure on a beaucoup mieux que
ça ça ne sert vous pouvez facilement
substitut elias dans l'usagé cuisson et
le chauffage de l'eau toujours avec de
l'électricité
là où ça commence à devenir vraiment
intéressant à mon avis c'est dans deux
usages c'est comme matière première pour
faire de la chimie
ça ce n'est pas inintéressant et le
deuxième usage qui paraît être
particulièrement pertinent c'est que
temps vous aurez pas fait revenir deux
millions de personnes dans l'agriculture
c'est pour la mécanisation agricole
donc à mon avis le premier truc qui est
intéressant avec la méthanisation c'est
de faire avancer les tracteurs tant
qu'on n'a pas convaincu les gens de
des membres et au lieu de remembrer de
revenir à la traction animale avec les
animaux qui font caca dans les champs
et d'avoir un peu d'être mécanique quand
même par dessus tout ça qui elle peut
être amenée par des engins qui
fonctionne avec du biogaz donc le
premier poste d'utilisation de la
méthanisation pour moi c'est que
l'agriculture se servait le même corps
le reste on verra après et dans les
transports c'est évident que ça sera
déterminante totalement marginal donc
aujourd'hui tous les gens qui vous
disent on va faire le segment terminal
de la livraison avec que des camions qui
fonctionne au biogaz grâce à la
méthanisation donc vous ferez quelques
réseaux de bus ça je veux bien
c'est aussi très intéressant avec les
ordures ménagères donc temps que vous
avez des gens qui habitent en ville et
qui jettent leurs pattes alors peu dur
de patates en ville et pas de nouveau
dans les champs ou pour noël et cochons
ce qui est en fait la meilleure
utilisation qui soit ouvrir les poulains
de loin la meilleure utilisation
eh bien tant qu'on n'en est pas là
méthaniser les déchets urbains
ça c'est aussi quelques jeux pour faire
avancer les bus c'est ce que fait lille
donc ça ça devrait vous plaire c'est une
très bonne idée ça pour le coup c'est
une très bonne idée
je voulais dire quand on entend
aujourd'hui les politiques parler on se
rend compte qu'on est encore bien loin
des enjeux un peu qui nous attendent on
va interdire les pailles points et
prochainement va c'est très bien mais à
côte ce qui nous attend on se demande
c'est pas un peu dérisoire et quand on
vous écoute parler vous avez qu'elle
fait que la démocratie la mondialisation
ne sera pas du tout le monde de demain
et ce que je demande et du coup c'est
comment on fait pour faire bouger ce
système qui est pas du tout adapté au
monde de demain
et est-ce qu'on fait + une méthode que
je dirais douce avec une des pétitions
démarche dans la rue qui au final bas
entretiennent aussi ce système
puisqu'elles sont dans ses cordes
ou est-ce qu'on fait une méthode plus
fortes où c'est la désobéissance civile
des printemps arabes qui sont
complètement contre le système mais qui
au final sont plus axés sur le système
demain je vais vous commencez par vous
faire un petit retour d'expérience sur
ma fréquentation qui maintenant n'est
pas loin d'être de 20 ans du pouvoir
politique il ya quelques petits éléments
qu'il faut savoir
la première le premier c'est que une
fois que vous êtes en fonction aux plus
hautes fonctions vous n'avez plus le
temps d'apprendre ce qui est un drame
mais c'est comme ça pour ceux d'entre
vous qui ont entendu parler de michel
rocard qui était un type que j'ai
rencontré une fois dans ma vie mais qui
m'a beaucoup impressionné il avait écrit
dans ses mémoires premier ministre c'est
un job dans lequel vous avez besoin de
prendre toutes les deux minutes une
décision sur un dossier que vous avez
pas eu le temps de regarder c'est encore
vrai aujourd'hui j'ai envie de dire
c'est encore plus vrai aujourd'hui
donc vous jonglez de la 5g à la pac en
passant par la pma pourquoi pour être
servi quelque chose là donc ils n'ont
pas le temps d'apprendre
la deuxième chose qu'il faut savoir
c'est que
la formation qu'ils ont suivie avant
leur entrée en fonctions incluent pas la
compréhension du problème de ce problème
à traiter
donc ils en entendent parler c'est pas
pour autant qu'ils le comprennent si je
prends un parallèle qui dans cette salle
a entendu parler d'internet où les
autres sont timides où ils sont souvent
mais bon vous avez tous entendu parler
d'internet qui dans cette salle est
capable de me décrire techniquement par
le menu le fonctionnement d'internet
personnes on est d'accord
et bien c'est alors c'est exactement ce
que je la voulais en venir beaucoup
entendre parler d'un problème ça ne veut
pas dire bien comprendre le problème
d'accord il ya une énorme différence ce
qui veut dire que à partir du moment où
ils n'ont pas la capacité à faire la
pédagogie du problème puisque ils ont
pas en eux-mêmes le bagage technique
pour le comprendre
ils en sont réduits à faire ce que fait
ou politique quand il comprend pas le
problème à traiter ces arbitres et des
pressions dit autrement ils vont dire
oui à la personne du moment qu'ils
exercent la plus forte pression c'est à
dire le le corps constitués ou la
fraction de l'électorat ou l'entité qui
fait que de lui dire oui amen le plus
grand bénéfice soit en termes
d'emmerdements éviter à court terme soit
en termes délecte de voix à long terme
c'est exactement pour ça que hollande a
dit oui ouvert sur le nucléaire je pense
que hollande ne sais pas vous décrire ce
que c'est qu'une fission nucléaire
je pense qu'il connaît pas le numéro
atomique de l'uranium qu'il a pas la
moindre idée de ce qu'on trouve dans les
déchets de fission et qu'il n'a pas la
moindre idée de l'énergie libérée par
une fission parce que tout ça il le sait
absolument pas et qui s'en contrefout
soit dit en passant mais par contre il a
compris que de dire ouvert qu'il était
contre le nucléaire c'est relais durable
et 3% des voix et comme il a été élu
avec 51 ans et demi il a eu bien raison
c'est exactement à ce jeu là qu'il a
joué ce qui veut dire que faire pression
sur les politiques et pour avoir côtoyé
longtemps hulot je vous l'eau avait un
pouvoir de nuisance qui consistait à
dire retenez moi ou je fais un malheur
alors je fais un malheur ça peut prendre
deux
voix je me présente aux élections et je
vous bouffe 10% des voix a fait pas sa
deuxième truc qui pouvait faire c'est
dire je dis je vous pourrit dans la
presse jeudi par tous du mal de vous et
c'est en fait la deuxième fois il n'a
jamais utilisé parce que c'est un pays
que mais par contre la première il l'a
vraiment utilisé au moment du pacte
écologique nous je me rappelle très bien
parce que j'étais un des co rédacteur et
il a vraiment dit c'était un coup de
génie il ya je songe à me présenter je
peux vous dire que le lendemain béraud
signé le pacte le surlendemain ségolène
royal signé le pacte
enfin d'abord le premier qui avait plus
à perdre a signé ensuite la deuxième qui
pouvait pas faire sans a signé et
ensuite sarkozy a été contraint de
signer et il en a terriblement voulue à
hulot derrière de l'avoir fait plier ce
que sarkozy était un mec qui n'aiment
pas trop qu'on fasse plier donc le donc
dans le monde politique vous n'existez
que si vous avez un pouvoir de nuisance
et alors c'est pas du tout de la
jalousie ce que je vais vous dire le
prenez pas mal mais moi j'ai jamais
réussi à rencontrer macron alors qu'aux
chiffres ça fait dix ans qu'on
réfléchisse à à quoi pourrait ressembler
des grands éléments de stratégie qui
serait à la fois bénéfique pour le pays
qui ramènerait de l'espoir et qui
permettrait de se coltiner cette
contrainte greta thun bern fait
descendre les jeunes dans la rue elle
est reçue donc je le redis c'est pas du
tout de la jalousie c'est juste très
emblématique du fait que c'est pas le
discours rationnel qui atteint ces gens
là ce qui atteint ces gens là c'est le
fact c'est là toute la capacité de
pression comment est-ce que vous existez
pour faire pression sur ces gens là eh
bien il ya que deux manières
ou bien vous rallier une entité qui fait
déjà pression sur eux donc vous trouvez
que ce que raconte greenpeace est génial
vous adhérez à greenpeace
si vous ne vous retrouvez pas dans
l'offre du moment qui militent pour
qu'on s'occupe sérieusement du problème
ou vous pensez que cette offre d'après
le pouvoir de pénétration suffisant
parce qu'il peut y avoir les deux
aux chiffres on a la prétention de
penser qu'on essaye de porter une offre
qui est en adéquation avec le problème à
traiter mais aujourd'hui on a un pouvoir
de pénétration qui est faible vous
pouvez très bien vous dire sont très
sympas mais je perds mon temps si je
vais chez deux parce que eh bien
à ce moment vous êtes un peu désarmée
c'est à dire que s'il ya ni offre
militante du moment qui correspond à ce
qui vous intéresse
ni vous n'avez en vous même une capacité
de nuisance et bien vous oubliez le
pouvoir politique à court terme
voilà c'est malheureusement comme ça que
ça marche il faut bien voir que je
pendant que le micro passe il n'y a pas
que dans l'action politique qu'il ya des
choses intéressantes à faire et en
particulier je pense que anglais en
général s'engager dans l'action
politique c'est quelque chose s'est
engagée dans le militantisme envers les
politiques c'est quelque chose que vous
faites pas ce que vous pensez que ça a
du sens mais vous pouvez très bien avoir
d'autres actions qui ont du sens j'en
reviens au manifeste de tout à l'heure
c'est une action qui a du sens mais je
vous assure c'est une action qui a du
sens le fait de démarrer des initiatives
locales
justement que avec le métier que vous
avez vous alliez aider à faire émerger
ici et là des fermes des marcheurs des
trucs et des bidules de la reconversion
urbains qui ont envie il ya un certain
nombre d'urbain qui aujourd'hui ont
envie de se reconvertir pour démarrer
une activité agricole qui souvent soit
dit en passant est pas fait exactement
comme les activités qu'il remplace il
essaye d'amener de l'innovation c'est
intéressant ce qu'ils font vous pouvez
très bien les aider donc vous pouvez
trouver du sens ailleurs que dans le
militantisme vis-à-vis du politique même
si je suis d'accord avec vous que c'est
toujours très irritant de voir des gens
dont on se dit mais qu'est ce qu'ils
attendent pour comprendre et c'est
particulièrement désagréable une fois
que soi même on a compris bonsoir vous
avez fait une très bonne transition avec
ma question
en fait étant donné que
le pib directement liées à la
consommation d'énergie on va avoir une
chute du pib
en tout cas on peut le souhaiter mais il
se trouve qu'une chute du pib dans la
structure actuelle de notre économie
ça amènerait directement à des
destructions d'emplois non comment faire
pour que la descente énergétique soit
socialement acceptable eh bien il faut
vous avez la réponse faut diminuer or
faut organiser la diminution du pouvoir
d'achat et cette organisation n'est
acceptable qu'à partir du moment où en
face vous arriver aussi à faire baisser
les charges alors la première charge
aujourd'hui c'est celle du logement on
va retomber sur ce que je disais tout à
l'heure
comme de toute façon pour des raisons
énergétiques il faut faire dégonfler les
grandes villes ça tombe bien
si je vous enlève 30% à votre salaire
mais vous allez dans un endroit où se
loger coûte 30% moins cher que par
ailleurs vous fait pousser une partie de
votre bouffe
bon bah vous achèterez moins de fringues
et brunes smartphone peut pas si c'est
très grave ce dont je suis intimement
persuadé c'est que la seule le seul
contexte dans lequel ce genre de choses
est négociable c'est si en face vous
amène de l'espoir dit autrement je vous
dégage le brouillard devant en vous
disant quand même tu vas devant là ça
monte un peu on va transpirer un peu
mais je dégage l'horizon et on est sûr
qu'on va pas tomber dans une crevasse
je pense qu'il faut absolument tenir ce
genre de discours mais on en revient à
ce que je viens de dire juste avant il
faut être capable de faire la pédagogie
du problème si on veut être capable de
vendre les forts face au problème
ce que je crois aujourd'hui c'est que
dans la population française
une partie des gens ont confusément
compris ils n'ont pas explicitement
compris il continue à tout confond ils
ont quand même confusément compris qu'il
y avait que demain ça allait pas être la
répétition d'hyères et qu' il y allait y
avoir des trucs bizarres
donc je pense qu'aujourd'hui quelque
part on n'est pas très loin de pouvoir
commencer à accompagner ce mouvement
déjà en expliquant moi moi je sais que
je me suis jamais fait sortir d'un
endroit où j'ai expliqué les choses y
compris à des syndicalistes cgt jeu
quand on explique les choses et qu'on
explique pourquoi effectivement il ya
des difficultés devant nous qui sont pas
liées à la mauvaise volonté de tel ou
tel mais qui sont juste liée à la façon
dont le système s'est construit en
général les gens sont d'accord enfin on
va discuter
il commence à avoir envie de regarder
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire et c'est
alors un truc qui revient
systématiquement c'est clair que
c'est dans une privation général le mode
de vie de bernard arnault est encore
plus intolérable et ça c'est vrai et
c'est un vrai problème
alors il ya plusieurs manières de faire
baisser la richesse de bernard arnault
il ya plein on peut rationaliser sa
boîte
enfin bon non mais plein de manières je
pense qu'alors je rebondis sur ce que
j'ai tout à l'heure sur les économistes
qui réfléchissent pas dans le bon
contexte jeu il faut probablement
réfléchir à des trucs comme ça de même
que tous les gens qui ont des pavillons
de banlieue qui vaudront plus rien dans
un monde à l'énergie contrainte parce
que c'est quoi une banlieue c'est la
zone où vous allez mettre des gens qui
sont indispensables à une activité de
type urbain c'est pas des agriculteurs
que vous mettez dans des pavillons de
banlieue c'est des emplois de bureau
donc vous mettez des gens qui font
partie du système énergivores et qui le
jour où le système énergivores n'est
plus là font partie d'une agglomération
qui n'a plus les moyens de trouver sa
subsistance à l'extérieur et d'une
agglomération qui est quand même trop
dense une banlieue pour trouver sa
subsistance en elle-même parce que c'est
pas avec un jardin ouvrier de 50 m² avec
vous allez faire bouffer toute la
famille toute l'année non donc le
pavillon de banlieue dans un monde en
contraction énergétique ma théorie c'est
qu'un jour il vaudra plus rien peut-être
qu'il faudrait anticiper le truc en
créant un fonds d'indemnisation pour
propriétaires de pavillons de banlieue
non mais il ya tout à inventer dans ce
monde là puisque c'est un monde qu'on
n'a jamais connu c'est une nouvelle
planification qui nous faut bien sûr
qu'il va une planification plus alors à
qeynos mais c'est quoi l'horizon de
temps qui 50 à 100 ans
bien sûr qu'il nous faut une
planification alors là je redis un truc
que j'ai dit tout à l'heure les français
sont les champions du monde de
l'optimisation sous contrainte
ils sont aussi c'est aussi le seul pays
communistes d'europe de l'ouest la
france est le seul pays communistes
d'europe de l'ouest
on est un pays foncièrement égalitaire
foncièrement égalitaire je veux dire les
les gens ça débecte mon voisin que je
gagne 10% de plus que lui enfin on est
un pays foncièrement égalitaire alors ça
peut avoir des côtés horripilant mais ça
aussi un énorme avantage face à la
contrainte que je viens de décrire
parce que justement on est un pays
accessible à l'idée de collectif on est
un pays dans lequel la part des
prélèvements obligatoires est très élevé
pour autant qu'on sort plus belle soit
dit en passant un mois j'ai fait des
petits calculs
quand la dépense de santé et de retraite
parce que c'est essentiellement ça qui
échappe aux prélèvements obligatoires
dans les autres pays passent directement
dans le privé
les gens sont pas nécessairement en
meilleure santé et ils n'ont pas
nécessairement une retraite plus sympa
donc l'idée qu'avec moins de
prélèvements obligatoires en supporte
moins en sortent mieux
c'est dur c'est de la foutaise de gens
comparent réfléchit plus loin que le
bout de leur nez le met donc dans ce
monde là on va avoir besoin d'un effort
collectif extrêmement développé je le
redis on a une chance en france c'est
qu'on est accessible à ça beaucoup plus
que les américains qui sont perdus pour
la cause pour l'éternité
donc aujourd'hui il faut qu'on ait
l'ambition d'imposer notre façon de voir
le monde aux américains et pas l'inversé
mais vraiment un jeu je suis sérieux
quand je dis ça j'ai mis vingt ans à me
faire à cette idée mais je le pense
j'ai vécu aux états unis quand j'étais
étudiant donc je viens de très loin mais
je le pense vraiment ce que ce que je
viens de dire
et il va donc falloir inventer une
planification
il va donc falloir inventer la façon de
de dégonfler de système et on va avoir
un débat très douloureux sur la question
démographique
parce que alors là je vais peut-être
choquer quelques unes et quelques-uns
dans cette salle je pense que le débat
du moment sur la pma et surréaliste
parce que dans un monde peuplé de 8
milliards d'habitants se demander
comment je peux rajouter des êtres
humains sur terre me semble pas être la
première priorité
mais vraiment je pense qu'on se prépare
juste à faire des gens qui sont
malheureux donc aujourd'hui c'est
l'exact inverse ce qu'il faut faire et
je vais reprendre le propos d'un père
jésuite que j'adore capelle gaël giraud
voilà qui a une vidéo faut mesurer ce
que ça veut dire chez un jésuite ce
qu'il advient va chercher un cadeau
il ya une vidéo de lui qu'ils tournent
sur internet dont vous pourrez aller
vérifier dans lequel il dit l'aide au
développement en france et il était chef
économiste de l'agencé française de
développement quand il a dit ça on peut
vous dire que vraiment eh bien
gaël a dit les trois priorités que
devrait avoir l'aide au développement
aujourd'hui les trois uniques priorité
devrait être l'éducation des femmes
le planning familial et les systèmes de
retraite c'est-à-dire tout ce qui permet
de contenir la démographie de façon j'ai
envie de dire raisonnablement tous
d'accord il faut se concentrer sur ses
trois trucs là et on oublie les ponts et
les routes et les aéroports et les
machins tout ça en fait une croix dessus
alors un peu de développement agricole
dans la mesure où c'est compatible avec
une démographie qui se calme voilà sinon
le problème est il juste bon il se
trouve que mon information de première
main sur les soirées chez vous revient
tout juste d'un stage à madagascar de
terrain voilà compter les zébus le début
c'est capital de paysans malgaches et
bien c'est très simple ce qui se passe
là-bas la population croit vous n'êtes
pas un homme si vous n'avez pas des
fichiers votre parcelle et donc les gens
vont couper la forêt qu'est ce que
voulait faire contre ça la seule chose
que vous pouvez faire c'est d'essayer de
changer le schéma dans lequel la
population croît indéfiniment il n'ya
pas d'autre chose à faire donc je je
sais mais c'est un débat difficile de
même qu'en france on va avoir un débat
sur les allocations familiales etc
c'est des débats difficiles mais ils
faut les avoir parce qu'à mon avis ne
pas les avoir c'est pire c'est la
régulation involontaire du système et je
rappelle aux agro qui sont dans cet
amphi que les populations animales donc
deux modes de régulation naturelle c'est
la famine et la maladie
vous vous rappelez famine et la maladie
alors la guerre c'est un accélérateur de
la famille et de la maladie c'est en
général ça qui fait des gros dégâts dans
une guerre c'est que les gens ont plus à
bouffer et qu'ils ont plus la
possibilité de se soigner les morts
directs dans le conflit je vous rappelle
que la première guerre mondiale a fait
moins de morts que la grippe espagnole
qui a suivi et dans les morts de la
seconde guerre mondiale vous avez
énormément de morts chez les civils qui
sont des gens qui sont morts de faim une
maladie énormément énormément donc le
voilà donc les donc ne pas accepter de
regarder en face ce problème là c'est
signé pour le fait que la famine et la
maladie et les guerres la côte détention
règle le problème de place je pense que
c'est mieux d'avoir un débat sur les
allocs bonsoir
j'avais une question vous avez parlé de
dégonfler les grandes villes qui pour
autant dans le rapport du giec de 2018
si je me trompe pas une des mesures qui
est présenté pour limiter
artificialisation des sols
c'est justement au contraire de
densifier les grandes villes et
construire au vertical pour le gérer
maximum de personnes sur un minimum de
terre donc pour vous à quoi ressemble la
ville du futur
alors je pense que la conclusion dont
vous me faites par que je ne connais pas
mais si elle existe elle vient du groupe
iii du giec
oui j'ai entendu oui alors est ce que
vous savez qu'il ya trois groupes dans
le giec noms qui n'ont pas du tout la
même valeur probante
le groupe 1 alors à ce que vous savez ce
que c'est que le gia qui tu es ce que
tout le monde a entendu parler du giec
attendez vous dit tout et l'autre jour
je connais quelqu'un qui est allé faire
une intervention à des jeunes de votre
âge dans une école d'ingénieur il a 80 %
qui savait pas s'il y en a qui savent
pas c'est pas une honte
non oui non bon j'ai quand vous le dire
donc le giec est une instance onusienne
qui a pour mandat de rassembler la
littérature scientifique disponible sur
la question de l'influencé de l'homme
sur le climat et d'en faire une synthèse
voilà c'est ça son club dans le giec
s'est décomposée en trois groupes le
groupe 1 parle de la physique du climat
et de la physique du changement
climatique donc là dedans vous avez
essentiellement des physiciens des
chimistes le groupe 2 parle des
conséquences possibles du changement
climatique est là dedans on aura déjà
mon groupe 1 vous avez des biologistes
parce que l'éthique du carbone aussi
dans le groupe 2 vous avez donc les
mêmes que les précédents plus des
biologistes et des médecins tout ça
reste à peu près sérieux dans le groupe
3 vous avez les économistes
vous avez les économistes exactement
donc dans le groupe 3 vous avez des gens
qui font tourner des modèles avec la
croissance infinie est la façon de
régler la taxe carbone dans un monde où
malgré le changement climatique et la
croissance infinie
voilà c'est ça que vous avez dans le
groupe 3 je fais partie des gens qui
pensent que le groupe pro n'aurait
jamais dû exister est en fait une partie
des gens dans les groupes 1 et 2 qui
pensent que le groupe pro n'aurait
jamais dû exister
la conclusion vous avez lu vient
probablement du groupe 3 et donc elle ne
peut être tenu que par des gens qui ont
à défaut de compréhension du système
dans son ensemble
donc à partir du moment où vous
comprenez pas que c'est l'énergie qui a
fait les grandes villes vous pouvez vous
dire ah bah oui quand même quand on fait
des villes qui sont très denses du coup
les gens se déplacent à pied plutôt
qu'en voiture
ouais c'est tout à fait vrai sauf que
les grandes villes très dense n'existe
que si vous avez beaucoup d'emplois de
services donc beaucoup d'énergie dans le
pays
beaucoup de pib à ce moment là du reste
les gens des grandes villes denses ont
beaucoup de pouvoir d'achat et comme il
n'aime pas vivre dans les cages à lapins
ils vont passer le week-end au maroc
j'ai pas si vous avez vu le sketch de
groland ah voilà c'est exactement ça
donc l'empreinte carbone globale des
habitants des grandes villes denses et
supérieur à l'empreinte carbone du
banlieusard de la boyer de ville qui lui
ne bouge pas parce qu'il fait son
barbecue chez lui le week-end et en plus
il a moins de pognon donc donc ce donc
j'ai longtemps pensé ça aussi qu'il
fallait densifier les villes mais en
fait c'est parce que j'étais pas encore
au bout de ma compréhension des effets
système donc maintenant je pense qu'il
faut dégonfler les grandes villes et
effectivement les petites villes qu'il
faut garder faut qu'elle soit dans ce
camp vous regardez le lutèce du de la
gaule lui tech3 qui avait cinquante ou
cent mille personnes
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils avaient 50 ou 100
mille personnes parce qu'à l'époque avec
l'agriculture qu'on était capable
d'avoir et bien une ou deux journées de
charrette à bras là pour en venir à ce
que je disais vous délimiter un disque
agricole qui était capable de nourrir 50
à 100 mille personnes donc point mais
dans le lutèce de l'ancien temps les
maisons étaient déjà serrées les unes
contre les autres et quand vous allez au
coach ou pas très loin d'ici
sans faire de la publicité pour personne
alors c'est pas le but est de l'ancien
temps mais c'est quand même le xième
siècle et bien vous voyez bien que dans
le vieux quartier latin vous avez des
apparts des maisons de deux trois étages
des immeubles de trois étages voilà 3 4
est arrivé le baron haussmann il a
plutôt fait 5 un peu plus mais donc du r
+ 5 ou 10 e art + 4 collés les uns à
côté des autres
c'est l'optimum de densité pour une
ville
d'accord vous fait pas mieux quand vous
commencez à faire des tours les gens ont
besoin d'espacé et vous laisse passer
les tours est en fait vous rendez compte
qu'en densité à l'hectare vous n'êtes
pas mieux loti vous êtes moins bien
lotis dans la tour parce que ces jeunes
un ascenseur sans électricité vous êtes
coincé donc le jour où il ya plus
d'électricité la valeur du foncier à la
défense dayraut 00 parce que le pdg de
total ne montera pas à pied au 50e étage
de la tour
je vous l'assuré enfin il le fera
peut-être une fois par mois parce que ça
les fera passer à tous les joueurs donc
donc voilà un exemple le foncier à la
défense dépend en totalité du fait qu'on
ait de l'énergie on peut valider sinon
ça vaut plus rien voilà donc le les
grandes donc les villes qui reste donc
la ville au petit valls et cahors si
vous voulez 20000 habitants tous dans le
mur d'enceinte est très dense et vous
faites à km et vous êtes dans votre
jardin potager ou faire pousser les
automates
alors je dis pas qu'il faut que toutes
les villes face à un mille habitants
mais ces images est ce que ce que je
voulais dire le le pari du baron
haussmann doit faire un million et demi
d'habitants est déjà à l'époque vous
avez des carrioles à cheval les trains
etc qui sont comme qui commence à être
capable d'acheminer des marchandises en
grandes quantités vers paris donc ça
vous donne une petite idée est une
mégapole à 10 millions d'habitants c'est
juste pas vivable
alors le problème évidemment c'est qu'on
est passé de la france agricole à la
france d'aujourd'hui de 30 millions
d'habitants à 65
et qu'est ce qu'on fait les 35
supplémentaire et envoie au débat que je
viens d'avoir juste avant je pense que
je sais pas ce qu'on en fait mais si on
passe de 35 à 40 on sera encore moins ça
c'est sûr
je ne sais plus
[Rires]
bonjour il ya peut-être un moment il ya
un paradoxe dans ce que vous dites c'est
quand vous vous croyez fermement la
phrase qui dit que paul une ressource
est rare c'est pas ça enfin j'ai pas
compris maintenant il ya un paradoxe
dans messager a perdu j'ai pas entendu
la fin de la phrase que vous avez évoqué
à propos des ressources plus une
ressource est rare c'est pas enfin à
vous non plus le montant
d'investissement en compte qu'on met sur
la table pour extraire une unité
supplémentaire de la ressource monte
c'est ça oui et si on considère
l'énergie comme une ressource
alors on va pas chercher à contracter
cette énergie on va juste dépensé plus
de moyens pour leur hockey aujourd'hui
alors on va repartir de lait des bases
vous êtes d'accord avec moi que le vent
est gratuit d'accord avec moi que le
soleil est gratuit est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec moi sur fait que le
pétrole est gratuit vous êtes d'accord
de pétrole et gratuit qui n'est pas
d'accord avec le fait que le pétrole est
gratuit le pétrole est gratuit
qui a payé quelque chose dans cette
salle pour que le pétrole se forme
personne donc le vent se forme
gratuitement l'eau tombe gratuitement
des montagnes et le pétrole qui les
montagnes sont gratuites aussi du rsa
sont formés gratuitement et le pétrole
la formation du pétrole gratuite dans
tous les cas de figure
ce qui coûte c'est le travail humain et
les revenus humains pour aller chercher
et ses revenus sur des composants de
morceaux la rémunération du travail donc
les gens qui travaillent qui ont une
action positive et la rente c'est à dire
les gens qui se trouvent juste être
assis sur la ressource et à qui vous
allez payer quelque chose pour qu'ils
consentent à s'en défaire
alors dans le cas du pétrole la rendent
c'est le pays qui détient le gisement il
ya une variante à la rente c'est du
passé sur le corps chose que l'on a
amplement fait dans le passé
ce qu'on a tout le moyen-orient a été
fait comme ça et puis pour le paysan la
rente cfa vardon et pour les pour le
vent la rendent chez le paysan qui va
vous dire vas tu plantes une éolienne
dans mon champ très bien tu vas payer
quelque chose dans les deux cas de
figure c'est des rentes et des salaires
de ce fait la fraction de la population
qui doit travailler pour extraire de
l'énergie de l'environnement est
d'autant plus faible que cette énergie
est déjà concentrées et prêtes à
l'emploi
c'est beaucoup plus efficace avec le
pétrole qu'avec le vent avec le pétrole
vous avez quelques pourcents avec les
énergies fossiles
il ya quelques pour cent de la
population mondiale qui travaille pour
extraire de l'énergie
si je prends une énergie dans le coût
d'extraction est 100 fois supérieur
c'est ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure 0,3
centime le kilowattheure pour le pétrole
stocké 15 centimes le kilowattheure pour
l'éolien d'accord donc je multiplie par
50 à ce moment là si j'ai quelques pour
cent de la population qui travaille dans
l'extraction des énergies fossiles soit
la x 50 puisque l'argent ne paye que des
hommes pour extraire la même quantité
avec des énergies renouvelables alors
employé 4% de la population active pour
extraire l'énergie je comprends ce que
c'est employer 200 % de la population
active pour exr d'énergie et plus de mal
oui c'est absurde employer 200 % de la
population active
c'est un peu dur de dépasser 100 ce qui
veut dire que si toute la population
active travaille et dans l'extraction
d'énergie avec de l'éolien ça de me
fournir est pourtant que la moitié de
l'énergie dont je dispose aujourd'hui
dont je ne saurais pas quoi faire
puisque soit dit en passant je n'aurai
pas le reste de la population active
pour de cette énergie faire fonctionner
des machines qui nous font nos produits
qui étaient d'accord donc dans un monde
qui est condamné à n'utiliser que des
énergies renouvelables à cause de ce que
je viens d'expliquer l'approvisionnement
énergétique globale sera
considérablement plus faible et donc le
parc de machines qui nous aidera dans
nos tâches musculaire sera plus faible
donc il faudra bien choisir là on les
utilise et personnellement pour
continuer un peu dans la provoc je
préfère qu on utilise ces machines pour
aider les paysans à désherber à la main
puisque avec des phytos est pas bien je
préfère que on est au trois robots
bouffeurs de l'image qui déservent à sa
place ça je veux bien plus tôt qu'on ait
des jets qui amènent des cohortes de
touristes chinois qui viennent acheter
des sacs ou bon marché pense pas que ce
soit totalement indispensable au bonheur
collectif futur après j'ai dû demain la
pierre là où j'ai jamais regardé donc
j'ai pas ça c'est peut-être levé depuis
longtemps
au prétoire la être vous avez la parole
bon ça si j'ai bien compris vous avez
exposé plein de chose merci pour ça et
si j'ai bien compris vous parler
principalement de la situation en france
et en europe
non je vous ai parlé de la situation
mondiale sur notre rapport à l'énergie
parce que ce que je vous ai expliqué sur
la diminution de la population agricole
quand il ya plus d'énergie dans un pays
c'est mondial ça ce que je vous ai
expliqué sur l'organisation c'est
mondiale ce que je vous ai expliqué sur
le fait que les machines avaient
transformé avait augmenté de puissance
musculaire par un facteur de plusieurs
centaines ces mondiale donc tout ça est
mondiale de ce côté là ok mais au niveau
des hauts niveaux des planifications par
exemple ah oui ça on est d'accord c'est
plutôt ça c'est la france mais ça c'est
à cause du traité de westphalie oui et
une deuxième question c'est par rapport
à la démographie
parce que grosso modo la population en
europe auxquelles a augmenté mais
relativement elle va augmenter
légèrement jusqu'au moment où elle
prêtera wallah soit abaissée ouais mais
comparé à d'autres populations mondiales
a pas d'accord et vous parlez de réguler
la démographie par exemple là
chine la chine la population a explosé
et leur empreinte carbone est en train
aussi d'exploser du coup quid de
l'échelle mondiale au niveau de la
planification en 1600 chez plus quoi il
ya un traité qui a été mis en place
entre les pays de l'époque qui s'appelle
le traité de westphalie et le traité de
westphalie dit une chose il dit les
états sont souverains
les états sont souverains d'accord
depuis cette époque il n'y a pas
l'espoir d'une quelconque gouvernance
mondiale ça ne peut pas exister parce
que charbonnier est maître chez lui
les états sont souverains ce qui veut
dire que quand je parle de solutions je
ne parle de solutions qu'à l'échelle de
l'acteur qui est capable de s'en emparer
donc il n'ya pas de maître du monde
donc personne ne va planifier l'économie
mondiale il ya quelques mètres de
l'internet mondial par exemple de ce que
peuvent s'occuper de planifier
l'internet mondial
donc si vous voulez changer l'internet
mondial il faut aller parler à ces gens
là et il faut aller leur parler soit dit
en passant en espérant que ça sera dans
leur intérêt sinon ils vous disent la
porte de sortie et parle à mon jeune ami
le donc comme les états sont souverains
tout ce que vous pouvez faire de mieux
c'est d'essayer d'influer au plus haut
niveau vous avez un décideur c'est à
dire l'état alors en europe on a quelque
chose d'un peu hybride soit dit en
passant parce qu'on a eu une entité
supranationale à laquelle on a délégué
un certain nombre de compétences
donc nous on peut monter à l'étagé
encore au dessus les soit dit en passant
les français le font très mal et très
peu comme les français sont les plus
intelligents du monde ça c'est notre
défaut il pense que si on fait des trucs
bien l'europe suivra que c'est pas la
peine d'aller faire le service après
vente
grosse erreur la délégation du seul land
de bavière auprès de la commission
européenne enfin la représentation du
land de bavière auprès de la commission
européenne est plus importante
numériquement que la représentation
française plus importante numériquement
donc nous on est totalement nulle dans
le fait d'aller faire valoir nos
intérêts auprès de la commission à
laquelle par ailleurs on a délégué un
certain nombre de compétences dont
notamment la réglementation
environnementale en europe donc si on
dit qu'on souhaite quelque chose pour un
pays bas le sol sur lequel on est un peu
de prises et ça renvoie à ce que je
disais tout à l'heure sur le fait d'agir
sur des gens qui ont eux-mêmes à pouvoir
de nuisance c'est le pays allait à
l'étagé au dessus c'est compliqué donc
ce qui est en train de faire quelques
atouts de berg en ce moment est très
utile pour remuer lakers et de nul effet
sur les décisions pratiques que pourrait
prendre un chef du monde qui n'existe
pas le la seule manière que vous ayez de
faire mieux c'est d'être militairement
supérieur et de dire au pays d'en face
tu vas faire comme ça sinon je t'en vas
y est j'ai les moyens de mon action mais
même ça c'est compliqué voyez les états
unis première puissance militaire du
monde ont essayé d'envahir le vietnam
ils sont pas bien arriver parce
qu'évidemment vous êtes toujours
quelqu'un en face qui dit c'est pas bien
et je vais je vais aider quand en face
ils ont essayé d'envahir l'irak ça a été
un résultat mitigé enfin ils ont
vraiment vas-y m'enfin on voit que c'est
un résultat mitigé donc envahir
militairement les autres pour les forcer
à l'action même chassé ses limites et
puis vous pouvez envahir un pays vous
pouvez pas en envahir 198 plus compliqué
donc le donc le le le
la difficulté dans l'action c'est que
vous ne pouvez pas agir d'entrée de jeu
à l'échelle de la planète donc ce qu'on
peut faire depuis la france c'est déjà
commencer par s'occuper de ce que fait
la france
est ce qu'on peut faire pour les pays
qui ont une démographie fortement
croissante c'est ce que je disais tout à
l'heure c'est s'occuper de trois trucs
qui sont à notre main puisqu'il ne nous
a pas ça ne dépend que de nous de
dépenser de l'argent pour éduquer les
femmes maîtres des plannings familiaux
et mettre en place des systèmes de
retraite
enfin aider les gens à mettre en place
des systèmes de fait c'est juste envie
qu'on en a donc ces trucs là on peut le
faire forcer bah c'est pas possible
alors il ya quand même un truc
intéressant à noter dans cette affaire
c'est que l'homme est un animal
mimétique tous les gens dans cette salle
qui ont acheté le même tee shirts que la
voisine où le voisin ou au contraire
surtout pas le même
wiki et c'est en fait ont eu un
comportement mimétique c'est comme ça
que nos parents nous élève soit dit en
passant
donc l'homme est un animal mimétique et
j'ai la naïveté coupable de penser que
si on commence à faire dans notre coin
des trucs qui sont pas idiots et
explicable
ça donnera des idées à tout un tas
d'autres personnes qui sont à tout un
tas d'autres gens qui sont dans la même
situation alors en l'occurrence toute
l'europe est aujourd'hui en contraction
énergétique
donc si on commence à faire des trucs
intelligents chez nous ça peut diffuser
chez les autres le japon l'est aussi
la corée du sud va pas tarder à y passer
les etats unis aussi
donc on peut très bien les états unis
m'intéresse moi on peut très bien donner
des le mexique va pas tarder à y passer
donc on peut très bien donner d d d
armes au travers de limitation à certain
nombre d'autres pays puis après c'est un
phénomène qui croit le dernier truc que
je voudrais rajouter c'est que de toute
façon dans cette affaire-là il faut pas
il ya pas de miracle
c'est à dire que les français adorent se
dire il ya une situation qu'a 14 là et
puis il ya un bouton sur lequel j'appuie
et à l'europe
tout se met en place comme par miracle
ça ça n'arrivera pas donc la seule chose
qui peut arriver c'est qu'à chaque fois
qu'on a une décision à prendre
on se demande où est la moins mauvaise
ou la meilleure dans les possibilités
qui sont à notre main donc c'est ça qui
fait sens se demander comment est ce
qu'on fait pour que le monde soit
merveilleux demain matin déjà il
faudrait qu'ils soient débarrassés tout
les emmerdeurs c'est pas possible
donc ça n'arrive pas donc ya pas de
baguette magique qui permet de faire ça
ce qui a du sens c'est à chaque fois
encore une fois qu'on est à un carrefour
et on y est très souvent toutes les
heures tous les jours toutes les
semaines c'est de se dire je vais aller
là plutôt que là
vu l'heure on va prendre encore une ou
deux questions non puis après allez
picoler
moi j'ai une question dont la
planification dont vous parlez ça passe
quand même par le territoire aussi on a
vu qu'il ya un grand roman brement du
territoire avec les nouvelles régions et
aussi le grand paris qui est quand même
un sujet avec celles ci ont beaucoup
d'ingénieurs vous sur mon travail et
outils
du coup je voulais savoir ce que vous en
pensiez est ce que vous pensez qu'on va
dans la bonne direction ce qui semble
qu'avec le grand paris se soit pas
vraiment une direction constructive à
long terme alors sur ce point vous avez
déjà la réponse
à partir du moment où je vous dis ce qui
est important c'est de faire dégonfler
les grandes villes c'est sûr que le
grand paris va dans la mauvaise
direction
donc non seulement vous allez déménager
sur plateau de saclay mais en plus c'est
pour une mauvaise raison même ballot la
deuxième
la deuxième question c'est est sûre les
l'organisation territoriale
en fait si je renverse je renverse le
problème est que je considère que notre
le premier déterminant de long terme de
la façon dont la société est capable de
s'organiser c'est l'énergie dont elle
peut disposer ses terres les machines
dont elle peut disposer sous contrainte
de co2 d'approvisionnement etc
je vais renverser le raisonnement c'est
à dire que je vais avoir envie de faire
un découpage territorial qui soit à la
maille de l'action qu'on peut avoir sur
un superbe sur un certain nombre de
choses mais pas complètement persuadés
que la région sur la bo de maya si vous
voulez faire des choses pertinentes sur
les circuits courts etc
vous allez plutôt être à la maille de la
commune ou des départements
si vous voulez faire des choses
intelligentes sur la normalisation vous
êtes de toute façon à la maille de
l'état si vous voulez vous voilà donc ça
va vraiment dépendre et je pense qu'il
faut renverser le raisonnement l'énergie
abondante nous a permis de faire
abstraction des contraintes spatiales et
des contraintes temporelles donc du coup
on a pu harmoniser les échelons
géographique de gestion mais dire tout
le monde aura des départements qui
feront à peu près jeu pourquoi 50 km sur
50 km
tout le monde aura une commune où ils
communauté de communes qui va faire sans
vie d'habitants
à mon avis raisonner comme ça c'est
mettre leurs raisonnements à l'envers ce
qu'il faut c'est repartir du problème à
traiter et voir à quel maille est ce que
vous avez besoin de planifier l'action
territoriale
on revient à aussi une sujet de
planification c'est de l'action
territoriale
après il ya aussi des choses sur
lesquelles s'est pas au niveau du
territoire que ça se joue ou plus
exactement il faut contraint de l'action
du territoire et alors je vais revenir
sur le sujet de l'urbanisme je fais
partie des gens qui pensent
qu'aujourd'hui il serait probablement
pertinente supprimer perdu construire au
vert parce que tant vous laisser permis
construire au maire ça sera l'anarchie
c'est à dire que chacun se poussera à la
roue pour construire encore plus chez
lui parce que ça lui fait plus
d'électeurs parce que ça lui fait une
plus grosse commune parce que toute
personne à qui vous avez donné un permis
de construire globalement il est content
donc il va voter pour vous parce que et
c'est donc le permis de construire au
maire c'est la garantie que l'étalement
urbain continue de façon illimitée parce
que ça crée des plus values et qu'une
partie de la plus-value foncière arrive
dans les caisses de la commune
enfin il ya toutes les incitations sont
là pour que ça pousse au visage et au
grignotage des orignaux tâche des terres
donc voilà voilà un exemple où c'est pas
le maire qui doit piloter l'action c'est
l'état alors que ça doit se faire de
manière locale
mais à ce moment c'est le préfet c'est
pas la mer voilà donc il ya la
discussion sur l'action est une
discussion qu'il faut replacer
j'insiste au droit du problème à traiter
et sur la gestion des eaux pluviales par
exemple la bonne échelle territoriale
ces deux bassins versants qui n'est ni
une commune ni un département d'une
région ni rien je vais pas y en avait
une l'arrêt depuis longtemps alors moi
j'ai ça fait longtemps donc par rapport
aux questions notamment sur sur la
viande
j il ya pas longtemps vu un reportage
donc sur netflix
voilà qui consomment beaucoup qui
polluent beaucoup aujourd'hui pourquoi
nous on n'est pas sensibilisés à toutes
ces questions là sur la consommation de
viande donc voilà je viens je suis
tellement dans le système je suis
relâché en école de commerce je n'ai pas
apprécié ce day 2 derrière mais bon
c'est pas grave sur l'économie vous
monde essaie de prendre conscience de la
chacun notre échelle de ce qu'on peut
faire et consommer moins de viande ça
ferait partie la solution quand on
apprend que 51 % des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre dans le monde c'est dû à
la production bovine aujourd'hui qu'elle
soit 51 ans ça dépend ça dépend quel
facteur de pondération et au métal en
émissions directes et indirectes en tout
cas on arrive à les chiffres à déchets
comme ça non non c'est moi qu'est ce
qu'on pourrait faire du coup pour pour
sensibiliser aujourd'hui la planète à
cette consommation de ces -
l'agriculture tout compris c'est 20 %
avec la déforestation c30 la
déforestation a notamment pour
déterminant l'augmentation de la
consommation de viande donc je veux bien
les mettre dedans et là dedans la partie
qui vient de la viande c'est aller je
viens la moitié ou les deux tiers donc
deux tiers de 30 ça fait vingt ça fait
pas 51 ça je viens que ça fasse 51 si on
prend le prg du méthane les émissions en
direct
non maintenant si on raccourcit
l'horizon de temps c'est une affaire de
forçage radiatif c'est pas une affaire
de périmètre le sujet de la viande moi
je suis pas d'accord avec vous il est je
pense en train de monter en ce moment
alors pour des raisons bonnes ou
mauvaises il monte pour des alors dans
les mauvaises raisons pour lesquelles
ils monde sait qu'il ya une fraction
croissante des français qui en mangent
moins de simplement parce que c'est cher
ça commence déjà à être un peu plus cher
il ya des gens qui en mangent moins pour
des raisons sanitaires
parce que à force de vous rabâcher que
de manger une entrecôte bien grasse à
tous les repas ça va vous boucher les
artères
il ya des gens qui se disent je vais
mouiller aller un peu plus mollo il ya
des gens qui en mangent pour des raisons
de moins pour des raisons de souffrance
animale
donc ça c'est aussi quelque chose qui
est en train de monter je ne dis pas que
c'est important dans la population je
dis tout ça c'est des petits machins et
par rapport à ce qui se passait dans le
débat public quand j'avais votre âge
quand j'avais votre âge tout ça
n'existait pas c'est à dire que quand
j'avais votre âge j'ai jamais entendu
parler de soucis la souffrance animale
c'était les bébés phoques
ça oui mais les vaches d'élevage ne tue
pas un sujet de souffrance animale le
sujet des artères ben ouais ça
commençait tout juste il y avait quand
même des histoires de cholestérol le
le sujet de la pression environnementale
non sujet absolu donc c'était
aujourd'hui moi je trouve que il ya
quand même un petit quelque chose sur la
question s'est pas encore un débat
totalement mainstream mais ya quand même
un petit quelque chose sur la question
j'ai le droit de rebondir ou c'est bien
sûr mais du coup aujourd'hui voilà on
est on est en europe on a conscience de
ça et aujourd'hui on a des pays
émergents donc effectivement la chine
l'inde et aujourd'hui encore on s'occupe
pas de l'afrique qu'est ce qui va se
passer parce que ces populations là sont
de plus en plus demandeurs de viande
comment est-ce que j'en reviens je n'en
reviens au mimétisme que j'évoquais tout
à l'heure à partir du moment où on dit
le régime normal est un régime fortement
carnet et en particulier avec des avec
des gros animaux
vous savez que historiquement
l'augmentation de la taille de l'animal
manger ou de sa qualité a été avec
l'augmentation de la plan énergétique
henri iv a dit aux français et mangez
donc une poule donc une valorisation des
shapes que la poule avait prouvé toute
sa vie il y aura 10 manger un peu de
viande la poule qui ont à manger du
cochon et mangé du boeuf en particulier
élevé pour sa viande c'est à dire pas de
l'animal de trait en fin de carrière
c'est quelque chose qui est très récent
puis avant je faisais pas ça donc cette
année d'augmenter c'est aller de pair
avec l'augmentation de la productivité
agricole sur les végétaux et aujourd'hui
80% des surfaces cultivables sont
dévolues à la production d'animaux à la
nourriture d'animaux donc cette histoire
de
de régime alimentaire est effectivement
un déterminant important
tous les gens qui s'offusque contre la
déforestation à bornéo et en remontant
des trucs que je le redis c'est est ce
que vous mangez beaucoup de viande est
est ce que vous achetez un truc avec de
l'huile de palme
parce que quand vous voyez d'huile de
pâques dessus il ya un petit bout de
route en dedans mais c'est c'est quelque
chose qui commence à émerger en occident
et plus vite on voudra que dans les pays
dits émergents il se calme sur ce sujet
là plus vite il faut que nous on
commence par le faire parce que quelque
part on leur sert de modèle
donc j'en reviens à ce que je disais moi
je ne contrôle pas le régime alimentaire
des gens dans les pays émergents par
contre ce que je contrôle c'est ce qui
se passe chez moi donc chez moi je peux
avoir un discours qui est si vous en
mangez moins il sait pas le bout du
monde
personnellement je dis pas ça pour me
vanter
j'ai quasiment arrêté de manger de la
viande rouge et pourquoi dix ou quinze
ans j'ai pas l'impression de me porter
plus mal et j'ai pas arrêté de manger de
la viande on mange moins voilà c'est
tout vraiment pas et dans les pays
émergents je le redis c'est culturel à
l'alimentation
c'est quand même un truc
fondamentalement culturel donc les
schémas culturels ceylan a modifié et
donc ça veut dire qu'à un moment il ya
des gens qui doivent initier un
changement et puis c'est une force c'est
long et c'est lent et voilà ça sera trop
lent à bâle pour finir sur une note
d'espoir de toute façon vous comprenez
bien avec ce que je vous ai raconté
qu'une partie de la claque on va la
prendre de toute façon et elle a déjà
commencé et elle a déjà commencé donc
dans cet amphi vous faites partie des
csp + + qui sont préservés déficit si tu
de la vie mais la claque elle a déjà
commencé
la déshérence des banlieues elle a déjà
pour partie commencée le fait que vous
ayez
la sécheresse de cet été elle a déjà
commencé donc il ya une partie de la
claque
elle a déjà commencé depuis une partie
des arbres qui ont souffert cet été ils
sont d'abord savoir commencer par l'été
prochain mais l'été d'après donc la
claque de toute façon on va pas
totalement l'éviter par contre est-ce
que comme disait l'autre puisque tout
est foutu il est encore temps d'être
pessimiste rogie non il faut de toute
façon se mettre dans l'action
parce que c'est notre meilleure porte de
sortie à tous points de vue d'abord
parce que se mette dans l'action ça
redonne le moral et ensuite parce que de
toute façon ça permettra toutes choses
égales par ailleurs de voir l'avenir
enfin d'avoir un avenir meilleur que si
on s'en occupe pas
[Applaudissements]